[Musique]
la lutte finale bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinker view nous sommes
en direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis un officier de marine qui dans
la partie embarqué de sa vie s'est
occupé de lutte sous la mer j'ai servi
sur des sous marins nucléaires d'attaqué
sur des frégates anti semaine ce qui
aurait vu octobre rouge ou le champ du
loup enter qu'ils peuvent avoir une
venue une bonne idée de ce qui a été ma
vie ou au delà des scénarios un audois
des scénarios et puis ensuite comme la
plupart des films marine dans une
deuxième partie hier j'ai eu la chance
de faire l'état choses très variées
c'est l'un des intérêts de cette vie
d'officier de marine en particulier de
militaires en général puisque je me suis
aussi aussi bien occupés de ressources
humaines de politique et rage j'ai
dirigé l'agencé de recrutement de la
marine est une très belle agence qui
devra coûter 3000 à 4000 jeunes français
chaque année me suis occupé d'affaires
européennes de conduite d'opération j'ai
dirigé un centre d'études stratégiques
j'ai été le camp demain à paris j'ai
dirigé un musée national un grand musée
national et puis j'ai dirigé une très
belle école qui s'appelle l'école de
guerre
oui très content pour souvent
aujourd'hui pour la saison 2010 22 on va
parler géopolitique on va parler soit on
va parler autant on va parler tout un
tas de choses
premier première boutade si je devais
planqué un sous marin russe ont fall de
en face de villefranche-sur-saône
villefranche sur mer c'est possible ou
c'est pas possible alors sous l'eau tout
est possible tout est possible en tout
cas on peut tout essayer
ensuite il y a des tas d'antagonisme de
relations de jeu qui font que même si
tout est possible sous l'eau et même
s'il s'y passe des tas de choses qu'on
ne raconte pas et il y a aussi des gens
lorsque vous voulez faire quelque chose
qu'ils sont censés au minimum vous
surveiller et voire même vous empêcher
de faire ce que vous voulez faire ça a
été une grande partie de ma vie j'ai
passé une partie de ma vie à tra et les
sous marins soviétiques et les sous
marins russes qui justement pensez vous
souhaitez voulait pouvoir faire en mai
dernier ce qu'il voulait eh bien la
france en face et puis avec nos alliés
que sont essentiellement dans ce jeu là
les etats-unis et à la grande-bretagne
nous nous évertuerons à ne pas leur
laisser le jeu trop facile
s'avère facile pourtant
ou question qu'est-ce qui quelles sont
les conditions pour une mutinerie sur un
bateau
jeu je ne sais pas si on peut avoir une
réponse d'ordre général très
certainement les circonstances la
culture des uns des autres des marines
de guerre ou de commerce
influence profondément ce qui pourrait
se passer
restons tout au fait tout néanmoins dans
le domaine du théorique
je pense que
si la mission
d'un équipage n'est pas comprise hausse
il n'a aucun sens on peut commencer déjà
à fragiliser cet équipage est ce qu'il
commande si vous rajoutez à l'absence de
sens
une profonde injustice qu elle soit à
l'encontre de l'équipage lui même ou à
l'encontre de ceux avec qui cet équipage
va se confronter se heurter ou
simplement échanger vous probablement
rendez là aussi les conditions d'un
éventuel mutinerie plus forte et puis
surtout surtout surtout je pense qu'une
mutinerie c'est d'abord un commandant
qui n'ait pas la hauteur de ses
responsabilités et plus encore qui n'est
pas la hauteur
de
ceux de voir qu'il a vis-à-vis des
femmes et des hommes qu'on lui a confié
qu'ils sont son équipage est donc très
certainement au delà des circonstances
la clé du démarrage d'une mutinerie
s'est très certainement très
certainement une problématique de
commandement et du commandant lui-même
à mon avis mais tout ça est assez
théorique comme on gère une mutinerie
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour reprendre le
contrôle de son avion
d'abord j'ai eu la chance de n'avoir
jamais été confronté à cette situation
donc donc je ne suis pas un spécialiste
la gestion ne la mutinerie je crains
qu'une fois qu'une mutinerie soit lancé
le corps n'en soit perdu je ne vois pas
très bien comment il pourrait ou alors
faudrait vraiment qu'un événement
exceptionnel
ensuite et là aussi c'est pour ça que
c'est théorique est ce que la mutinerie
a été lancé sur des choses qui étaient
totalement justifiée ou est-ce que ça ne
l'était pas c'est une question difficile
mais je passe je sais pas si vous avez
vu ce livre qui s'appelle us s alabama
qui est l'histoire d'un sous marin
nucléaire américain qui reçoit au cours
d'une ne s'est pas trouille en temps de
paix normal l'ordre d'ouvrir le feu et
puis je trouve que le message reçu n'est
pas complet et ça génère abord une
terrible scission entre une partie de
l'équipage derrière le commandant qui
disent il faut que nous ouvrions le feu
et le second et nos parts et l'équipage
qui disent non tant qu'on n'a pas reçu
l'ordre complète donc la procédure est
pas complète on peut pas ouvrir le feu
et je n'avais pas vu ce film mais je
savais ce qu'il racontait et puis se
trouve au cours d'une de mes
commandements je commande un vision et
nous sommes partis quatre mois dans le
pacifique une émission assez longue et
au milieu de cette mission un soir pour
pour animer un peu la vie du carré dont
des officiers qui étaient autour de moi
je leur propose ce soir je vous emmène
au cinéma et au milieu du pacifique est
donc très bien compris que je devais
n'est pas complètement fou ce que je
vais faire mon jab et du maître d'hôtel
près par neo un bon dîner et on s'est
habillé en civil comme si vraiment on
allait sortir le soir deux mois qu'on
vivait ensemble coupe est loin de tout
et que on en avait encore pour deux mois
et j'en dis et puis on va se faire donc
une soirée au cinéma et on va aller au
cinéma et après le film on fera un dîner
débat donc assez artificiel on s'habille
en pékin pour le dîner le reste de
l'équipage se dit ça y est ils sont le
coran est devenu fou et monsieur les a
plutôt fait rire on passe le film est à
seysses alabama et pendant que je vois
ce film que j'avais jamais vu jusque là
je me dis catastrophe il n'y aura pas de
débat parce que pour moi c'est
absolument évident que il se trouve en
l'occurrence dans le film que c'est le
second qui avait raison et qu'il ne faut
pas ouvrir le feu pour moi c'était
évident et donc je passe à table en
disant merde alors ma soirée débat
animée ça va faire un flop et je
commence le dîner en disant ça a bien
fini bon bah je suis désolé j'espérais
un débat intéressant mais ça fait gaffe
et là je vois stupeur d'au moins la
moitié de mes au physique il dit et
pourquoi pas du tout et je découvre
qu'en fait dans mon propre état major il
y avait à peu près la moitié des gens
qui comme moi pensent et que évidemment
c'est le second qui avait raison et
l'autre moitié qui pensaient que
évidemment c'était le pacha est en fait
du coup on a eu un super dîner un débat
absolument génial tout ça pour dire que
la perception des choses c'est très très
personnel et c'est très difficile a
priori de se dire ben hilli à un camp
qu'ils aient raison il y en a un autre
qui l'a pas alors il ya des cas où celle
là où c'est très clair mais parfois
c'est plus compliqué et contrairement à
ce que j'avais pensé en regardant le ssl
là bas m'a effectivement on a eu un vrai
débat pendant ce dîner parce qu'on
n'était pas du tout d'accord sur cette
histoire alors juste pour terminer c'est
très intéressant c'est que ce film-là
terminer sur cette histoire ce film-là a
fait changer la procédure américaine
d'ordre et de tirs de leurs sous-marins
nucléaires lanceurs d'engins on va
parler on va continuer par le sous marin
est un peu un peu après quelle est votre
perception de la situation de la france
à l'heure actuelle en termes économiques
en termes militaires et long terme
futures
c'est une vaste question
je pense que
la france n'est bien il est en plus une
grande puissance et depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs il n'ya plus en europe
occidentale de grandes puissances je
fais partie de ceux qui aimeraient bien
que l'europe l'union européenne devienne
une grande puissance mais aujourd'hui ni
l'union européenne parce que ne l'est
pas encore devenu et je fais partie de
ceux qui tous les jours le déplore et
j'en suis vraiment triste ni aucune des
puissances européennes ne sont des
grandes puissances et donc prétendre
pour un français que la france son pays
serait encore une grande présence ce
serait juste ridicule
néanmoins néanmoins je suis convaincu
que la france est un pays particulier
ceux ci d'ailleurs de ne pas nous léguer
des prétentions et un égo stupide des
mesures est totalement déplacée mais au
contraire nous léguer une permanente
exigences de qualité dans notre analyse
du bond de pertinence de notre regard
sur le monde et puis d'engagement nous
sommes puissance particulière pour plein
de raisons légué par l'histoire les
guépards ce que nous sommes et je vous
en donner un exemple très très précis
très clair mais avant cela plus je
médite ce genre de sujet plus cette
phrase incroyable jaune à l'ohl qui dit
il existe un lien multi séculaire entre
la liberté du monde et la grandeur de la
france est bien plus je pense que le
général de gaulle avait raison il existe
un lien multi séculaire entre la liberté
du monde et la grandeur de la france et
je crois qu'il a raison parce que nous
avons une position particulière à cause
de notre histoire à cause de notre
capacité nous français a conceptualisé à
cause de ce que nous avons donné à cause
de notre capacité à regarder le monde et
d'ailleurs est sûre le monde entier à la
france aujourd'hui à fond aujourd'hui le
seul pays au monde sur lequel le soleil
ne se couche jamais
notre territoire maritime qui est le
premier territoire maritime de la
planète fait que nous sommes le seul
pays au monde sur lequel le soleil ne se
couche jamais et donc nous avons un
regard sur le monde nous avons eu des
actions seulement pas toujours heureuse
mais nous avons nous sommes appliqués
dans le monde et ça ça nous permet
normalement
d'avoir des idées intéressantes sur le
monde et ça nous engage parce que
beaucoup de gens
pensent que nous sommes intéressant j'ai
eu la chance de faire l'école de guerre
aux états unis chaque année la marine
française envoie quatre de ses officiers
faire l'école de guerre à l'étranger aux
états unis en grande bretagne et en
allemagne et puis un an sur deux en
italie en espagne il va néanmoins je
devais faire l'école guerre je suis
celui qu'on a envoyé aux états unis et
là j'ai découvert tout au long de
l'année que de manière très intéressante
aux états unis l'obsession des
professeurs américains c'est de faire
comprendre aux officiers américains que
le monde est plus complexe que ce qu'ils
croient eux les américains
ce sont des professeurs qui ont un
immense culture une vraie compréhension
intelligente du monde d'ailleurs j'ai
jamais compris comment des élites
américaines où c'est exceptionnel ce que
les états unis sont un pays qui ont des
élites exceptionnel
comment ces élites aussi exceptionnel ne
passe-t-elle pas plus sur la politique
étrangère bien souvent catastrophique de
ce pays c'est très étonnant quand tu vas
à l'école de guerre je voulais en écho
n'avoir oil colette ya des professeurs
exceptionnels et il se trouve que leur
vision du monde est très proche de la
vision naturelle du français et donc
l'officier français de la promo les
professeurs passent leur temps à lui
demandé tu en penses quoi parce qu'ils
savent que le français va répond quelque
chose d'intéressant qui est proche de ce
que eux croient ou les professeurs et
c'est ce qu'ils essayent de faire
comprendre aux américains et de la même
manière à chaque fois que les étrangers
dans la promotion de l'école de guerre
du neuf mois au collège nous étions 250
tv 35 étrangers les étrangers à chaque
fois et c'est arrive assez souvent
qu'ils ont un truc à raconter aux
américains eh bien systématiquement et
je suis convaincu que ça n'est pas
arrivé tout au long de mon année à cause
de moi je suis convaincu que chaque
année c'était la même chose avec the
lancet chaque fois que les étrangers ont
un truc à dire aux américains pour les
attentions le monde il est pas comme ça
nous on pense autrement eh bien il se
tourne vers le français et ils attendent
de lui que ce soit le premier à parler à
dire sauf blague et ça pour moi c'est
une fois une anecdote mais c'est aussi
extrêmement révélateur est emblématique
de cette position particulière de la
france nous nous sommes évidemment plus
une grande puissance nous ne sommes pas
une grande puissance mais sont nous
sommes une puissance très particulière
et ceci nous engage ce signe est une
vraie exigence pour que nous nous osions
d'abord que nous bâtissions une vision
du monde intelligente et que nous osions
la dir est certain que quand on se perd
dans nos querelles de gaulois ou quand
on fait que du nombrilisme métropolitain
ça on risque pas d'être à la hauteur de
cette exigence mais je suis persuadé que
cette exigence française existe et cette
phrase de charles de gaulle qu'on
pourrait trouver grandiloquente ou en
fait je crois qu'elle est profondément
vrai il existe un lien multi séculaire
entre la liberté du monde et la grandeur
de la france je pense que c'est vrai
alors quel est notre avenir là dedans
très honnêtement
on peut se poser des questions
voire même être inquiet aussi parce que
le crétinisme villageois gaulois ça fait
plus de deux mille ans que ça dure et il
n'a pas l'air de se terminer parce que
trop d'entre nous n'ont pas conscience
que il faut lever le museau et pas se
regarder le nombril
parce que ils les élections
présidentielles qui arrivent
je sais pas ce qu elles vont être je ne
devrais pas crier au loup avant d'avoir
un mois avant d'avoir la queue mais
ne l ont pas l'air de démarrer à
destination à la hauteur des situations
mais ce dont je suis persuadé c'est que
si nous ne sommes pas capables de bâtir
l'union européenne
et je pense qu' aucun pays plus que la
france ne peut être un moteur pour cela
pas la france tout seul mais un moteur
pour cela si nous ne sommes pas capables
de bâtir cette union européenne dans les
grands à des antagonismes actuelle dans
le retour et la folie des empires c1
pour moi pour l'ancien directeur d'école
gars je suis il ya quatre grandes causes
de risques de conflits dans le monde
le premier c'est le retour à la folie
des empires pour le moins des états
nations et vous voyez bien que même si
c'est fini mais l'amérique de trump
c'est pas fini ces points l'eau ou
encore la chine de ces jean ping
l'a la turquie d'erdogan la russie de
poutine vous rajoutez à ça le brésil de
bolton a row ou bien que bouffe
c'est pas gagné
la paix l équilibre du monde s'il n'y a
pas la capacité à faire émerger une
union européenne qui elle pour des tas
de raisons parce que c'est son histoire
peut faire comprendre au monde que iliad
audio le drame
le drame et je vous reviendrai ensuite
sur les trois autres causes de conflit
le drame et je suis sidéré que ça ne
soit pas plus compris c'est que le monde
est régi par ce qu'on appelle les gens
l'oublient aujourd'hui que c'est dommage
on devrait tous relire thucydide il en
parle très bien le dialogue mais lien
qu'est ce que c'est que le dialogue mais
bien le dialogue mais lien c'est cette
histoire dans la grèce antique à la fin
du 5e siècle avant jésus-christ athènes
prend le leadership et le pouvoir dans
la grèce à la fin des guerres médiques
mince qui se termine à l'égard mixer les
agresse ses délégués entre la grèce et
les perses
à la fin des guerres médiques en 480
avant jésus-christ grâce à la bataille
navale de salamine la grèce pas
définitivement les perses et ça se fait
sous l'égide et sous la halle à le
leadership d'athènes et athènes a
utilisé pour cela pour fédérer les cités
grecques quelque chose s'appelle la
ligue de délos en 480 la guerre contre
les perses est terminé mais la ligue de
délos perdure parce que athènes
l'utilisent comme un outil
pour assurer son pouvoir soir c'est
d'ailleurs fascinant de regarder le
parallèle auront exactement il
exactement entre athènes et la ligue de
délos les états unis et l'otan les
perses dont la menace a disparu l'union
soviétique dont la menace additionnelle
c'est vraiment absolument fascinant il
se trouve que cette ligue 2 de hausse
permet à athènes de régner sur la grèce
ont à peu près 70 ans et au bout de
soixante dix ans les autres cités
grecques et en particuler sparte en ont
marre c'est le début de ce que tu sud
raconte dans ses guerre du péloponnèse
donc c'est le début de la guerre du
péloponnèse et il ya un épisode tout
effet si noir et c'est là que je voulais
en venir de cette guerre de perez quand
on s'appelle le dialogue mais lien c'est
que mais là c'est une petite île de la
mer egée alès de sparte un peu plus près
d'athènes meilleur au sud est d'athènes
et l'emilien évidemment tu t'es dit le
dit pas mais mais l'os et du côté de
sparte
athènes débarque et dit amel hausse il
faut vous payer un tribut parce que dans
la ligue de délos soit vous donniez des
troupes on trouve le temps soit vous
payer un tribut c'est le pays le tribut
que la plupart des pays européens
aujourd'hui paye aux états unis via
l'otan pour soi-disant assurer leur
sécurité alors que je suis pas
absolument certaine plus désunie ça les
intéresse toujours confiant bref
revenons à la ligue de délos
et et à l'ordre mais liens et donc mais
l'os répond à athènes non non on veut
pas payer notre tribu d'abord nous
sommes une petite cité ne très pacifique
c'est parfait ne sont pas neutres sont
que des spams ils disent nous sommes
neutres nous sommes pacifiques et nous
en appelons au sens de la justice
d'athènes et athènes répond il n'y a pas
de justice entre puissances inégal à
thème assiègent la cité
la femme force sa reddition tue tous les
hommes et réduit femmes et enfants à l'
esclavage et athènes libyen il n'y a pas
d'injustice dans l'heureux événement d
un des hommes lorsque les puissances en
jeu ne sont pas égales et dans ce cas-là
l'effort dictent leur loi et les faibles
leur obéissent
l'ordre du monde est régi par le
dialogue mais liens s'étaient viderait
ya 2500 ans c'était vrai il ya 50 ans ça
sera encore vrai dans 200 ans on peut le
regretter mais c'est comme ça l'ordre
mais lien c'est l'ordre du monde je vais
même vous donner une anecdote plus
récents mais qui est beaucoup plus qu'un
d'autres dont je suis sidéré qu'elles
soient pas plus connus qui prouve à quel
point ça n'a pas changé
davos 1997 davos pas porto a l'air ou
bombay josé bové et ses potes
altermondialiste davos la mecque de la
bien-pensance de l'économie occidentale
aisée riche davos 1947 se termine souza
sur une table ronde
tour de table on demande à un
représentant des cinq continents de
répondre à la question suivante à qui
appartiendra le 21e siècle
le premier à répondre son petit ressort
répond police états unis c'est un jeune
économiste déjà très connu qui appelle
jeffrey sachs qui dit bon le xxème
siècle se termine je termine sur la
toute puissance des états unis alors il
développe sa plus longuement je vais
faire maintenant mais il y joua pas
pourquoi ça changerait et donc
pronostique-t-il le 21ème siècle
appartiendra aux états unis pas de
réactions de la salle pas de réaction du
congo le deuxième qui parlent parlent
pour l'asie c'est aussi oublier son nom
un jeune économiste qui est le ministre
de l'économie de l'inde de l'époque un
garçon qui a fait ses études à oxford ou
à boston
et idy et développe ça il ne serais je
suis pas d'accord il suffit d'ailleurs
de regarder la taille des tours de hong
kong ou de shanghai qui aujourd'hui sont
plus haute que celle de manas a presque
fait tout un développement et il
explique que c'est à la zik appartiendra
de 21e siècle là vous avez la partie de
la salle
un peu plus jaunes d'oeufs de figure de
poids que les autres qui applaudit avec
la réserve et la mesure habituelle de
ces pays asiatiques le troisième qui
parle et blanc mais pas pour l'afrique
un colosse sud africain quel ministre
nous oublié son nom de l'économie de
l'afrique et de l'époque est pareil dit
je suis pas d'accord c'est pas vrai
hockey en afrique pour l'instant c'est
un peu la pagaille les grands lacs sont
à feu et à sang on a le sida ben tout ça
on va finir par le réseau de vie ne
serait ce que pour des raisons
démographiques et donc lui aussi il
explique que c'est à l'afrique
appartiendra le 28 août la partie la
plus sombre de la salle qui applaudit
avec là aussi l'enthousiasmé la chaleur
que nos amis africains peuvent avoir et
ça va manifester le quatrième qui
parlent parlent pour la mairie le sud
c'est pas les anneaux exactement des
olympiques mais il se trouve que l'un
est de la même manière il dit ok ça peu
la pagaille chez nous il ya la
corruption la social la situation
comique est pas top mais la partie plus
importante du monde sait les amériques
la partie n'a plus qu'à le plus de
vitalité dans les amériques c'est
l'amérique du sud est donc lui aussi il
démontrer il dit que c'est un mec
jusqu'à maintenant le cinquième qui
parlent parlent pour l'europe c'est le
ministre un ministre français d'époque
qui parle à peu près bien l'anglais donc
selon lui ai dit c'est toi qui t'y cole
et il est catastrophé parce qu'il entend
les autres et se dit mais qu'est ce que
je vais raconter je veux même pas moi
aussi raconter comme les quatre autres
ballot que c'est à mon continent que
moby sont tous arrivés il faut qu'il se
lance
alors il dit deux choses edit bon le
xxème siècle vient de se terminer nous
les hors pair on en n'est pas très fier
parce qu'on a légué au monde de guerre
épouvantable mais néanmoins il ya deux
choses dont nous sommes fiers nous
européens la première c'est que c'est
nous qui avons inventé l'idée de la
démocratie il ya très longtemps déjà
depuis la grecque antique et on a offert
sa au monde et s'en est plutôt fier et
bienne deuxième chose dont on est encore
plus fier
c'est que nous sommes en train de bâtir
aujourd'hui au sein de l'union
européenne entre ces pays qui se sont
entre déchirés pendant des décennies
voire même des siècles quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est l'union européenne
c'est l'idée que le jeu n'est pas à une
somme à le monde n'est pas un jeu à
somme nulle mais on peut tous en tirer
est dit il moi je pronostique que le
xxième siècle sera le premier siècle de
l'histoire de l'humanité qui
n'appartiendra pas un continent mais à
tous
je trouve que il s'en est plutôt pas mal
tiré
silence de mort dans le congrès est
alors que le protocole ne l'a pas prévu
l'indien qu'elle fait ses études à
oxford cambridge ou à boston on reprend
la parole et lui dit je ne suis
absolument pas d'accord le xxième siècle
sera un siècle de fer de feu et de sang
ou nous viendrons vous écrasez parce que
vous n'êtes que des occidentaux décadent
et l'as tonnerre d'applaudissements
interminables ont tous le congrès feinte
davos 1997 alors je me lève pas tous les
matins en me disant où est ma
kalachnikov ou et mon casque lourd il
faut que je me protège alors en plus oui
mais j'ai fini il existe plus de femmes
à saint louis absolument mais mais si on
n'a pas compris que l'ordre du monde
c'est l'ordre mais lien on a rien
compris au monde et dans ce monde où un
comme je disais tout à l'heure
effectivement le retour et la folie des
empires est la première menace sur la
paix du monde dans ce monde où
deuxièmement je veux dire comme ça parce
que aujourd'hui il ya des sujets qu'on
peut pas aborder qu'on n'a pas le droit
d'évoquer mais je vais le formuler
plus cette formulation et est assez
forte que moi je la trouve assez elle me
convient le deuxième la deuxième cause
de risques potentiels sur la paix du
monde c'est ce que je vais appeler le
choc de l'islam et de la modernité la
troisième cause ce sont les conséquences
des évolutions économiques et
démographiques je suis sidéré qu'on ne
regarde pas plus la démographie parce
que la démographie ça vous dit ce qui va
se passer à 30 ans vous connaissez un
seul sujet aujourd'hui sur lequel on
peut se projeter à 30 ans de manière
certaine et un à quinze c'est la
démographie il voit bien que dans un
monde où on nous étions un milliard
d'êtres humains il ya à peine un siècle
et où nous serons 10 milliards d'êtres
humains dans 20 ans
ça peut être compliqué surtout lorsque
vous coupez ça avec les réalités
économiques et puis le quatrième le
sujet de risque est probablement le plus
important en tout cas qui est celui qui
a la probabilité d'occurrence la plus
grande ce sont les conséquences
géopolitiques des évolutions
environnementales et climatiques
regardez combien aujourd'hui il est déjà
compliqué parce que c'est compliqué
seuls les imbéciles ou les malhonnêtes
prétendre que c'est accompli combien il
est compliqué de s'occuper de gérer ces
quelques dizaines voire centaines de
migrants qui traversent la méditerranée
la montée des eaux dont je sais pas
assez les pour dans 5 ans à 15 ans dans
50 ans j'en sais rien mais elle a
commencé la montée des eaux va mettre
hors de chez eux un milliard et demi
d'êtres humains y ça va se passer
facilement dans un monde régi par le
dialogue mais liens non bien sûr que non
ça va être compliqué et donc si nous
français nous comprenons pas que
l'émergence d'une union européenne à la
fois forte qui peut parler peser dans le
monde et qui a aussi parce que pendant
des siècles nous sommes entre déchirés
qu'on a fini par le comprendre où on
avait fini par le comprendre je me
demande si aujourd'hui on s'en souvient
encore donc si cette union européenne
n'émerge pas
le monde va être très compliqué il va
être content très compliqué parce que
l'ordre mais lien
n'est pas un ordre de performance c'est
le bordel l'ordre mais lien ça ne marche
pas
et c'est une solution qui régit le monde
mais dont il faut absolument que la
société civile comprennent qu'elle n'est
pas la solution la performance ne naît
pas de l'ordre mais lien l'ordre mais
lien génère le chaos et le désordre et
tant qu'il n'y aura pas un ordre
international mais depuis l'émergence
donc la tentative de la société des
nations 1 puis l'onu cet or
l'international on le voit vraiment pas
vraiment pas arriver est en ce moment en
ce moment c'est encore pire tant qu'il
n'y aura pas d'ordre national et il y en
aura pas en tout cas pas avant très
longtemps
l'ordre maignien continuera à générer un
monde de chaos il ya deux réponses à
cela la première réponse pour la société
civile est probablement d'ailleurs on
continuera en parler c'est ce que
j'appelle l'esprit d'équipage ont
l'esprit défonce l'esprit de défense
d'une part mais ensuite l'esprit
d'équipage c'est ce qui va vous
permettre la performance dans ce que
vous faites que ce soit appliquée à la
défense ou à d'autres sujets et puis il
ya malgré tout une bonne raison de
continuer à avoir de l'espoir ce que ce
que je vais raconter c'est désespérant
on sait absolument des espérances juste
réaliste mais c'est réaliste seulement
ce qui est désespérant d'ailleurs ça ne
pas dire ça c'est de nos fusées
exactement c'est un de le refuser et de
ne pas se mettre en action pour y
répondre pour moi l'une des réponses
possibles et en partie par la société
ville et à partir pour le monde de
l'entreprise c'est la recherche de la
performance parce que j'appelle l'esprit
d'équipage et la deuxième raison qui
fait que malgré tout le monde continue à
fonctionner et je pense même à ne pas
aller plus mal c'est ce que j'appelle en
tout cas moi c'est ma théorie des
clairières c'est qu'il se trouve que
heureusement il y a dans le monde
partout des hommes et deux femmes des
hommes et des femmes de bonne volonté
qui dans tous les domaines à tous les
étages la société
développe autour d'eux une clairière qui
permet au monde non seulement de ne pas
agresser mais de continuer à vivre et je
pense malgré tout à progresser et donc
mais dire cela et avoir l'espoir que ces
clairière nous permettent de continuer à
imprimer d'améliorer
ça n'est pas fermé les yeux dans un
monde qui de manière géopolitique et
macroscopique est régi par l'ordre mais
liens et pas par autre chose c'est pas
vrai tout ce qu'ils racontent autres
choses sont des coupables
pour pour anticiper il faut il faut
prévoir il faut prévoir si on n'anticipe
pas on perd quel regard vous portez sur
toutes ses cellules de prospective que
nos ministères ont qui n'ont jamais rien
anticipé qui ce
qui rompt rendent dans des salons
feutrés
qu'est ce que vous pensez sur notre
capacité à anticiper
d'abord je crois que beaucoup de nos
organismes
quel qu'il soit que ce soit dans ce
champ que vous venez d'évoquer ou
d'autres sont hélas en cac est dans une
culture de l'existence est pas dans une
culture du résultat
c'est à dire que les gens ici ou là
surtout là-bas mais en en particulier la
barre du grand père entendu qu'ils
enseignent keller s'est d'ailleurs est
ce que je vais décrire je crois hélas se
rencontre partout vous avez deux types
de personnes vous avez celle qui se lève
le matin pour exister
je veux d'ailleurs je prends mon exemple
au sein du ministère que je viens de
quitter on arrive à son bureau le matin
et on a une fiche à faire pour sa
hiérarchie ou pour un organisme il se
trouve que en fait si on affiche ses
deux secondes bien souvent pas tout le
temps bien souvent on prendrait son
téléphone on appellerait la personne en
charge la problématique on le dirait
coûte paulo voilà ce que je pense à
mende et il faut faire ça à faire serait
réglé sauf que si l'affairé réglée de 8
après vous avez plus de job vous
n'existez plus
donc vous faites une fiche qui va être
beaucoup plus longue à rédiger qu'un
simple coup de téléphone de trente
secondes puis ensuite votre fille vous
allez à passer à votre haine plus un
puits où en plus de plus enplus 3 avait
compté moi lorsque j'étais j'ai passé un
an au au centre de opérationnelle des
armées qui avait sept niveaux de
hiérarchie entre mois rédacteurs et
celle d'un major des armées évidemment
ces niveaux ils prennent la fille si la
lisent ils la font monter ils la font
descendre on vous la renvoie on vous dit
là vous allez remplacer vite par rapide
et sauf que le niveau d'eau du sud et
non en fait on va mettre rapide c'est
mieux que vite voilà et tout ça fait que
la fif elle va permettre à certaines
personnes de vivre pendant trois jours
cinq jours une semaine parfois plus et
donc là on existe on n'a pas réglé les
problèmes que vous avez des gens
évidemment qui simplement sont dans une
culture du résultat et qui hésite mais
non moi j'agis pour que quelque chose
change et que ça serve à quelque chose
pour apporter une valeur ajoutée la
problématique c'est que évidemment ce
que je racontais caricatural mais la
caricature
tout ça peut être excessif message in a
très souvent ça explique exane est donc
ces gens qui sont ces organismes dans
une culture de l'existence d'abord bien
souvent il ne cherche pas à changer le
monde ils cherchent à exister pas et le
premier problème existe et vous avez
bien compris ce que ça voulait dire
derrière et puis le mans
si déjà ces organismes se disait
maintenant on va intervenir pour que à
chaque moment chacune nos actions soit
une valeur ajoutée déjà probablement
c'est là mais il ya un deuxième problème
qui est très important c'est l une de
mes obsessions quand je commandais
l'école de guerre deuxième problème
c'est que nous ne préparons pas l'avenir
et nous ne serons pas des acteurs utile
pour le monde qui émerge quel qu'il soit
si nous n'avons pas la capacité à penser
autrement
penser autrement est la condition de la
survie de tout système de tout organiser
mais pour cela une fois il faut non pas
faire tous les jours des choses
autrement lorsque pour un sujet connu
vous avez des recettes qui sont connues
et dont vous savez quelle marche il faut
pas être débile appliquer les recettes
qui marchent mais il faut être en
permanence dans cet état d'esprit qui se
disent je dois être prêt à penser
autrement et je dois me préparer à
penser autrement ça c'est fondamental
parce que si on ne la prend pas au
quotidien à penser autrement ces
problèmes que nous ne connaissons pas
encore qu'il nous faudra résoudre dans
deux ans 5 ans 10 ans nous serons
incapables de les résoudre et pour
penser autrement il faut au minimum
d'être mené que fut grande école
non je crois pas qu'il faille mettre le
feu aux grandes écoles je suis pas sur
le système des grandes écoles à plein
davantage il a plein d'inconvénients
mais il a aussi des avantages et donc je
suis pas sûr que ce soit je prendrai que
je vais redire ce que je voulais dire et
puis je vais revenir sur un exemple des
grandes écoles à partir sur les nerfs
sur les mains parce que je vous vois
venir et donc sur les mains pour pouvoir
penser autrement il faut d'abord
en permanence être convaincu que la
culture est indispensable et qu'il faut
sans cesse se cultiver et cherché à se
cultiver ça c'est la première condition
la deuxième condition sans galvauder ce
mot tu étais totalement galvaudé
aujourd'hui on raconte n'importe quoi il
faut créer de la diversité une
et diversité pas la diversité à la noix
dont on nous rabat les oreilles tous les
jours dans le monde médiatique
d'aujourd'hui mais une vraie diversité
en allant chercher des gens qui
véritablement sont différents viennent
d'endroits différents c'est déjà une
question de géographie
c'est aussi une question de parcours
c'est aussi une question de différence
d'âge c'est toutes ces choses là qu'il
faut mettre en place et donc culture et
diversité c'est fondamental pour être
pense capable de penser autrement et il
n'y aura pas de construction d'un monde
un peu moins mauvais que l'actuel voire
même d'un monde bien meilleur si on
n'est pas capable de penser autrement
revenons à votre problématique des
grandes écoles et avec le cas très
intéressant et emblématique de l'ena
je pense pas que le problème de l'ena
c'est l ena en soit
le problème de l'ena c'était que il faut
dans un système qui essaye de construire
et parcourt la sélection et le parcours
des hommes et des femmes qu'ils
recrutent plus qu'il va utiliser ensuite
il faut au minimum trois étapes il faut
une première étape qui est la sélection
initiale
quelle qu'elle soit mais faut une
sélection initiale autant que ce soit
sur des critères intelligent et qui se
projette dans la durée et pas simplement
dans le court terme mais il faut une
sélection et d'issia
et peut penser que la sélection initiale
à l'ena était pas si mauvaise que cela
je suis pas sûr que le problème était là
bien au contraire pour avoir rencontré
au cours de la guerre sont des marques
certains au titre des dons mais j'en ai
croisé que j'ai trouvé absolument
remarquable et très intéressant donc la
sélection initiale à mon avis on peut
toujours l'améliorer et l'on pouvait
sûrement la meilleure j'ai pas sûr que
ce soit le prévoir mais d'abord il faut
une sélection initiale intéressante
ensuite et c'est là que ça commence à
déraper dans ce système il faut et pour
tout système et ça n'était pas le cas
l'ena il faut un temps de passage
suffisamment long dans la vraie vie
parce qu'il n'y a pas de construction et
de parcours initiatique
s'il n'y a pas un temps de passage
suffisamment long dans la vraie vie et
c'est fondamental et sa très
probablement ça manquait à la haute
fonction publique française et puis un
troisième temps qui est nécessaire et
qui n'existait pas dans la fonction
publique française et là encore
évidemment alors quand c'est un aussi
général qui veut dire ça il peut
paraître suspect mais il se trouve qu'il
ya un très très bon modèle est ce qu on
le fait bien sûr une question bien trop
mais c'est les collègues il faut une
troisième étape qui est une nouvelle
sélection à mi carrière pour choisir ce
qu'ils vont devenir les grands patrons
et bien évidemment sur des critères
différents de ceux de la sélection
initiale parce qu'on cherche pas la même
chose et c'est ça qui est très important
et c'est ça qui n'existaient pas et
c'est ça qu'il fallait apporter à la
fonction publique française à la haute
fonction publique j'espère que ça qu'on
va lui donner mais c'est donc bien après
une sélection initiale quelle qu'elle
soit un vrai temps de passage
suffisamment long dans la vraie vie et
ensuite de nouveau une sélection qui
peut être très dur dans les armées la
sélection pour l'école de guerre c'est
seulement 20% des officiers
qui se présentent mais c'est 20 % de
ceux qui se présentent ils se présentent
quasiment tous s'ils veulent avoir une
carrière maman mais c'est seulement 20%
de ceux qui se présentent et tous ceux
qui sont intéressants aux belles lettres
se présente ça veut dire que 80% des
officiers ne vont pas franchir
c'est à dire qu'on va les tuer et le
mettre dehors mais on va les utiliser
autrement contraire ils ne vont pas
devenir les grands patrons
imaginez imaginer dans la fonction
publique française on dise aujourd'hui
hier à tous les énarques à 35 ans vous
repasser tous un concours on ne prendra
que les 20% meilleur c'est eux qui
deviendront les grands patrons bois
ouvriers le tsunami et momo métaphore je
peux l'étendre à la société civile gère
imaginer que dans tous les grands
groupes c'est plus compliqué évidemment
pour des pme imaginez dans tous les
grands groupes ont 10 à tous les
polytechniciens les hfc les centraliens
les essec tous ceux sortis du système
des grandes écoles françaises ou
l'équivalent on leur dit à 35 ans on
rebat les cartes pour passer un concours
comprend pas que les 20% meilleur waouh
c'est ce que font les militaires et ils
ont raison et donc dans un système vous
n'avez pas une première sélection
initiale intéressante évidemment plus
elle sera large plus il sera diversifiée
au bon sens du terme meyer elle sera
mais ensuite
vrai parcours initiatique dans la tente
pas ça chez vous à mon avis puis une
troisième sélection ouais ça c'est sûr
avec cela
on génère pas forcément les chefs qu'il
nous faut et donc c'est pas un procès
des grands écoles en soi que je fais
parce que je pense qu'elles ont plein
d'entre elles ont des inconnus ils sont
pas là d'ailleurs à mon avis des plus
grands inconvénients ils ont pas là ils
sont ailleurs mais c'est bien le procès
et parcours que l'on bâtit après qu'à
mon avis il faut faire plus que ceux des
grandes écoles qui sont des lieux où il
ya malgré tout une vraie sélection
perfectible une vraie sélection qui sont
des lieux qui demande pour la plupart de
ceux qui passent à vrai ton
apprentissage en particulier dans le
parcours des prépas et donc qui sont des
lieux qui malgré tout sélectionne des
gens qui sont qui sont intéressants la
seule chose c'est qu'on les a
sélectionnés sur leurs qualités
intellectuelles c'est les conditions
nécessaires c'est pas les conditions
suffisantes or en particulier pour
choisir des chefs le plus intéressant
c'est les conditions suffisantes c'est
quand les conditions suffisantes ce sont
les qualités humaines c'est le parcours
c'est l'expérience qu'on a acquise c'est
la remise en cause que sans cesse on
était capable de faire de soi même c'est
toutes ces choses là mais c'est pas un
procès en soi des grandes écoles elles
sont à mon avis un début d'étape qui
n'est pas si mauvais que cela pour moi
le problème et il n'est pas là pour plus
grand problème des grandes écoles c'est
que ça attire tous les soi-disant talent
dans 1 ou dans une seule case et un
certain nombre d'entre eux en fait tu
aurais pu être infiniment plus
intéressant ailleurs que là où le
système les a renvoyés
va parler
un petit peu mécanique
vous avez dit et pas celle d'un sous
marin non j'ai pas été passée de ce
machin non non non j'ai pas été
passionné ce moment il se trouve que
dans la marine après pour les gens qui
comme moi ont fait l'école navale après
l'école navale et après les premières
années même de navigation vous devez
choisir un domaine de spécialité c'est
là où moi j'ai décidé de venir un
spécialiste de la lutte anti sous marine
comme d'autres vont devenir des
canonniers du specis des missiles ou
d'autres vont aller 6 et des mécaniciens
se perfectionner plus encore dont on
choisit un domaine de spécialisation
pour en tout cas pour les opérationnels
comme moi pour se spécialiser dans un
domaine de lutte et il se trouve que
j'avais choisi chacun j'avais envie j'ai
choisi de devenir un spécialiste de
lutte sous la mer
et je pensais et je comptais faire une
carrière de surface y est chasseur de
soumah et je pensais que le meilleur
endroit où je pourrai apprendre mon
métier de chasseur de sous-marins
c'était dans un sous marin est donc ce
qui se faisait pas pour pour plein de
raisons d'ailleurs bonne ou mauvaise
mais parce que c'est vrai que c'est bon
mais peu importe et donc j'ai dit est ce
que je peux aller apprendre à la sortie
de cette école qui a fait de moi un
spécialiste de les buts sous la mer
est-ce que je peux aller vraiment
apprendre mon métier de chasseur sous
main dans sa surface et j'ai eu la
chance qu'on me dise oui et c'est pour
ça que j'ai passé deux ans et ce matin
j'ai eu une deuxième chance c'est que
l'oph six opérations de mon bateau dont
celle de ses directeurs des opérations
c'est le numéro trois du bateau c'est la
cheville ouvrière du bateau je suis pas
un job très facile et celui qui était
sur le bateau je suis arrivé un peu un
plus comme sur facile dans ce tour on se
demandait qu'est ce qui venait faire là
c'est pas très facile d'ailleurs au
début va arriver sur fassiez par htc le
zumba est signé ils m'ont eu mon pas
accueilli hyper bien au début c'est
assez intéressant et il se trouve que
l'officiel personne mon bateau faisait
pas là frère donc il s'est fait vider et
après avoir pour ce que je n'étais qu'un
imbécile puisque c'était surface ils
sont dit mais il a pas l'air si couillon
que sa surface et donc celle venant
fesser par action de mon bateau qui
était absolument passionnant et ensuite
je suis redevenu sûr partie de l'effort
de surface pour y apporter mon savoir
faire de chasseurs de soudain donc j'ai
pas comment national j'étais en revanche
officie opérations de 2 et senna
l'émeraude pulsé fier
donc quand on se retrouve dans une boîte
de conserve
vingt mille lieues sous les mers qu'est
ce que ça fait de savoir qu'en face ils
ont des torpilles à hyper cavitation
salle à une hyper cavitation nous
torpiller hyper cavitation alors avant
de répondre à votre question je crois
c'est mes souvenirs sont bons que à
l'époque comme c'était souvent gagné il
savait pas encore c'est torpilles ils
les ont eu peu de temps après mais il
les avait pas encore à ce qu'une
torpille et l'hyper cavitation c'est
c'est pour aller simplement en gros
c'est plus notre pays c'est une sorte de
missiles sous marins c'est à dire que si
vous voulez c'est une torpille qui va
extrêmement vite sous l'eau et donc vous
avez plus à gérer quelque chose qui va à
30,40 euros + 59 sous l'eau mais vous
vous avez à gérer quelque chose qui va à
la vitesse d'une balle de carabine quoi
donc vous voyez bien que la défense
c'est pas la même la défense c'est pas
la même qu'est ce que ça fait on essaye
d discrets alors de toute façon là la
première nécessité le premier combat
sous l'eau c'est effectivement d'être
discret et de ne pas se faire repérer
ce que je veux dire est aussi et
simplificateur et caricatural puis
citation vous m'entraînerai pas aussi
loin peut-être que vous le voulez mais
en gros vous êtes repéré vous êtes mort
donc le but c'est vraiment de ne pas
être repéré celui qui tue c'est celui
qui n'a pas été repéré et celui qui tue
et c'est celui qui est qui et repère
c'est simplificateur mais c'est pas très
loin de la vérité donc le grand combat
sous l'eau c'est d'entendre sans être
entendu ce n'est pas facile les
sous-marins d'aujourd'hui ils font moins
de bruit que le bruit de fond de la mer
que krill entre autres que parce que
comment je serai beaucoup de bruit c'est
le monde du silence n'est pas le monde
du silence c'est à se demander alors
c'est un titre c'est un titre très
politique mais se demander s'ils
construisent vraiment aller sous l'eau
c'est tout sauf le monde du silence
c'est extrêmement brillant et en plus
tout s'entend sous l'eau et tout porte
infiniment loin mois les premiers
passages sous marin soviétique que j'ai
pu faire avant d'être sous marinier ans
était sûr de frégate anti sous marine
c'était des sous marins qui ont
lampistes ra entre 100 et 200 km2
ce qui est assez confortable parce que
même si lui vous repère le temps qu'ils
voyaient que anhalt en
trois ans après je suis sous mariniers
et je me souviens de
deux pistes âge où on se raser la
moustache avant avant de cette entendu
de s'être entendues vous voyez que c'est
pas la même chose et puis en plus sous
l'eau tout peut arriver parce que on
peut vous rentrez dedans la guerre ça
arrive il ya des collisions entre sous
marins et qu'est ce que vous pensez du
bugle et de brens
alors
le bugaled breizh n'a pas été coulé par
un sous-marin c'est juste impossible
et il serait temps que enfin on le
reconnaissent c'est impossible pour
qu'un sous-marin plonge sous l'eau il
faut deux choses qui puisse avoir au
moins 50 m dos au dessus de lui pour des
raisons de sécurité que tout le monde
peut comprendre et qui les 50 m dos
entre lui et le fond
sinon c'est dangereux pour lui comme en
face de villefranche c'est ça en face de
villefranche bien vite de l'eau beaucoup
d'eau en face de filtrage alors mesdames
il ya très vite de l'eau donc pourquoi
sous marin puisse plonger et donc pour
qui les 50 m dos au dessus de lui et 50
m dos en celui il faut donc au minimum
100 mètres de fond
le bugaled breizh a coulé par 80 mètres
de fond
il ne pouvait pas y avoir de sous marin
en plongée à cet endroit là c'est juste
pas possible c'est comme si vous me
racontiez comme vos copins s'est fait
faucher par l'aileron arrière d'un nerf
bus qui passait sous le pont de l'alma
au moment où lui traverser le pont c'est
juste pas possible
ça c'est mon premier point et qui met
les yankee cela il n'y a plus rien à
dire
ensuite
il est impensable qu'un marin quel qu'il
soit qu'il soit sur un bateau noir
assouma sur un bateau gris une frégate
de la marine française de notre frégate
ou sur un bateau de commerce ou sur
pêcheurs et mais encore plus de marins
de la marine nationale française il est
absolument impossible qu'un marin
puisse mettre en danger un autre marin
sans allés lui porter secours c'est
juste impossible
c'est pas pensable et troisième élément
aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés
occidentales modernes et démocratiques
on ne peut pas cacher de tels faits
c'est pas pensable mais voyez comment
plus mes deuxièmes et redémarrer mans il
de toute façon ils sont même pas utile
le premier fait qu' il pouvait pas y
avoir de sous marin en plongée s'étendre
là c'est pas vrai c'est du n'importe
quoi c'est du n'importe quoi d'ailleurs
si vous voyez moi je les ai vus pendant
des jours puisque sa coque était à
l'entrée l'arsenal de brest tous les
jours en allant au boulot je passais
devant le bugale breizh on voit bien que
les enfoncement de la coque sont
parfaitement symétrique donc les
enfoncement de la coke ont été provoqués
par la pression de l'eau s'il y avait un
choc les enfoncement n'aura pas été
symétrique le nombre de gens qui m'ont
dit wright a vu les photos des enfants
ce mandat comme quand on les enfonce
mandat coque on voit bien qu'il était
frappé par quelque chose vous vous êtes
débile ou pas
il est extrêmement clair même sans être
un ingénieur que c'est un enfoncement
par la pression de l'eau
alors alors plus on sait très bien que
le bigard de bresse à l'endroit où la
coulée trois jours avant il avait une
croche et qu une croche et le chalut qui
s'accrochent dans l'eau ils l'ont fait
sur le fond et s'il à ce moment là
l'équipage ne décroche pas le chalut
extrêmement vite ce qu'est ce qui n'est
pas facile le bateau étant et est
entraînée et écoute il avait fait une
croche au même endroit quelques jours
avant
alors pourquoi pourquoi tous ceux ce tas
de son nature là pour pour trois raisons
d'abord que ça c'est plutôt une qualité
c'est que dans la communauté
du monde de la pêche on ne critique pas
les morts je le porte plutôt à leur
crédit donc on peut pas accepter l'idée
qu'ils ont pas pu réagir assez vite
sachant que c'est vraiment pas les
critiquer parce que c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile donc
deuxièmement hélas hélas il ya l'appât
du gain et d'ailleurs vous verrez que
toutes ces histoires là toutes ces
histoires là le jour il n'y a plus de
recours juridiques possibles elle
s'arrête on n'en parle plus jamais et
puis troisièmement il y à l'excitation
la folie la bêtise des médias
quelque elle quel regard un ami al comme
vous porte sur le monde médiatique en
détails quelles et quel est votre source
d'information comment vous faites pour
vous informer quel regard vous portez
sur nos médias
je suis pas sûr très honnêtement que je
me pose
cette question
peut-être parce que j'ai peur des
réponses que je pourrais leur apporter
mais même si je n'ai pas d' analyse
rationnelle réfléchi sur ce sujet
je suis assez effaré
de ce que je lis je vois au j'entends
je suis assez effaré des sujets dont on
nous parle
moi je regarde plus la télé française la
seule télé que je regarde encore quand
je regarde la télé
c'est ces france 24 en anglais
ah bon ça peut faire un peu d'anglais et
et parce que malgré tout france 24 parle
du monde
s'intéresse au monde et je trouve que
c'est important
je suis assez étonné lorsque je lis dans
les journaux des sujets qui sont des
sujets pour lequel 2 3 connaissance de
voir bien souvent au mieux
l'approximation au pire les
contre-vérités qui sont écrites
et alors c'était mon troisième point je
suis sidéré qu'on ne soit pas capable
de sortir de cette mauvaise foi de ce
dogmatisme des uns les autres moi si je
crée un reçu c'est pas bien c'est juste
pour répondre à vos questions mais si
secret à un grand journal mais la
première chose que je ferai gilles à
chercher les journalistes de tous les
bords politiques
et d'ailleurs à commencer par ceux qui
sont pas les miens et puis simplement je
leur dirai les gros je ne sais pas
appelé pour que vous veniez nous
raconter des conneries mais simplement
pour que justement vous on puisse penser
autrement que votre ouverture et donc
que soyez totalement libre d'écrire ce
que vous voulez écrire mais mais
simplement écrivez-moi des trucs que qui
tienne la route et qu'ils sont
intelligents intéressant et qui sont pas
des mensonges dogmatique
mais que que c'est très inquiétant je
vais je vais glissé parce qu'en fait en
fait c'est un peu le même sujet et
d'ailleurs ils s'en prennent ils sont
ils sont alimentés par ça aujourd'hui
dans la sphère des parrainages
j'ai absolument pas enfin tous
maintenant je suis plus un officier
général d'actifs je peux dire ce que je
pense j'ai absolument nous vendons
réserve de cinq ans non il va devoir
réserve toute ma vie mais il ya des
choses que je que j'aurais peut-être
padilla et il ya peu de temps mais que
je peux dire maintenant mais après tout
le jeu l'assument et et surtout ça pour
donner du poids à ce que je dis après je
n'ai pas l'intention de voter ni pour
zemmour n'est pour le pen ni pour
mélenchon mais je ne voterai pas pour
eux a rajouté pécresse en demandant la
liste non je dis non mais vous allez
voir pourquoi je vous parle de ça toute
façon
savez lire vote il peut tout me savais
mais qu'il ne puisse pas se présenter
ces trois candidats qui représentent
quasiment la moitié la moitié du corps
électoral français c'est un scandale et
qu'une personne qui se targue de 4%
d'intentions de vote face à leçon en
disant qu'il n'est pas question que ces
gens là puissent se présenter mais c'est
juste sidérant c'est inadmissible c'est
inadmissible
et cette idée qu'on ne change pas les
règles en cours de jeu mais je vais
trouve complètement calme oui en règle
générale on change pas les règles en
cours de jeu mais moi je suis désolé
lorsque je fais un jeu et que je me
rends compte que les réactions
totalement idiote
et ben soit j'arrête le jeu soit si le
jeu doit continuer je change les règles
je change les règles en quoi à partir
d'un moment on a reconnu collectivement
démocratiquement majoritairement que les
règles ne sont pas bonnes en quoi
faut-il s'obstine élan corp et je leur
dis bien et c'est pour donner du poids
au fond de ce que je raconte sur ce
sujet j'ai pas l'intention de voter ni
pour mélenchon ni pour les mots ni pour
le pen je trouve ça scandaleux qu'il ne
puisse pas se présenter je trouve ça
juste ce qu'on a fait pour moi c'est un
déni de démocratie et l'idée qu'on
puisse pas changer les règles parce que
le jeu est lancé mais je suis désolé
alors ça c'est vraiment pas pensé
autrement j'accepte pas ça et pourquoi
pas changer les règles si on est tous
d'accord qu elles sont connes change on
les voit c'est idiot change on lit pas
n'importe comment après tout on devrait
être capable entre nous on en discute en
ou en tout cas ce qu'on a qu'on a nommé
pour nous représenter la représentation
nationale s'ils sont pas capables entre
et vu le nombre de sujets à la noix dont
ils sont dont ils parlent tous les jours
où tous les soirs où on trois exemples
de sujets loin j'en sais rien c'est
désespérant ouvrez votre télé regarder
ce qui se passe à l'assemblée nationale
et vous en aurez vite 3
qu'on se mêle de tout et n'importe quoi
elle voulait un sujet à la noix tient à
ce sujet la noire c'est un détail mais
je veux dire je comprends pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui la loi impose un certain
nombre de départements français 2 au
mois de décembre mettra chez tout le
monde des pneus neige mais c'est juste
débile je dis pas qu'il faut pas tu ne
neige mêlées sont les gens être juste de
ça en quoi
la pauvre grand mère qui prend sa
bagnole de temps en temps dans l'hiver
sans jamais sortir de sa ville où toute
façon il y aura jamais de neige et elle
était lobbies et à les mettre des pneus
sur sa bagnole que le type qui va sur
une route de montagne régulièrement qui
sait qu'entre chez lui et l'endroit où
il travaille au cours de l'hiver mais en
plus il les a déjà parce qu'il n'est pas
que you donc voilà vraiment un sujet
totalement débile pourquoi imposer à
tout le monde d'avoir des pneus neige
dans un sanglot départements français
mais on fera mieux de se poser des
vraies questions que quoi sur quelles
sont les réelles qui permettront à des
candidats qui sont légitimes qu'on les
aime qu'on les aime pas qu on ait envie
de voter ou qu'on n'ait pas envie de
voter point je suis désolé il me semble
assez clair sur ce que j'ai sur les
trois autres mais que zemmour le pen et
mélenchon se présente aux élections
présidentielles moi je trouve ça
légitime
question internet est ce que dit alors
je connais pas le nez bien est-ce que
désarmer le batral dumont d'urville
bâtiment logistique de surface capable
de plage et n'est pas une erreur
stratégique
alors il se trouve que pas sur les
grandes villes sur le francis garnier
qui était un sistership même c'était une
version un tout petit peu plus ancienne
mais c'était la même chose c'est loupé
c'est mon premier tôt ce primate haut
sur lequel j'ai servi le francis garnier
aux antilles après mon temps les canaris
sur la jeanne d'arc donc je connais
assez bien ces bateaux là
d'abord on désarme à bateaux parce que
il est devenu trop vieux
il faut avoir conscience que garder des
bateaux très longtemps non seulement ça
fait qu'on a des bateaux qui sont
obsolètes mais en plus ça coûte très
très cher le coût de maintien en service
d'un bâtiment
tabac tout en général un fonctionner
d'un bateau de guerre c'est exponentiel
dans la durée donc ça coûte beaucoup
trop cher et puis en plus ces bateaux
ils sont obsolètes donc désarmée le
dumont d'urville ya même pas de
questions il fallait le faire la
question qui à présent derrière celle
de votre internaute c est ce qu on
n'aurait pas dû remplacer le du monde
hautvillers cette classe par une
catégorie de bateaux qui peuvent
continuer à plat j'ai
la réponse maintenant il faut et je
connais pas suffisamment ses nouveaux
bateaux mais il faudrait voir qu'est-ce
qu'on a perdu en perdant les battre à
halle qu'est-ce qu'on a gagné avec les
bateaux qu'ils ont remplacés
quand on fait un nouveau bateau on a des
nouveaux avantages on peut perdre des
choses très honnêtement le ratio entre
ce qu'on a gagné ce qu'on a perdu je
sais pas répondre je pense quand même
que le niveau les nouveaux bateaux sont
plus intéressants que les anciens est-ce
que c'est dommage qu'on puisse pas plage
et la réponse est probablement oui c'est
probablement dommage l'ag ça veut dire
qu'on va j'ai ça veut dire alors que ces
bateaux là c'est des bateaux qui pouvait
s'approcher suffisamment
jusqu'aux plages
pour poser leurs étraves sur la plage
leur étrave s'ouvrait et à ce moment là
vous pouviez sortir du bateau soit parce
que ces bateaux initialement ont été
conçus pour emporter une compagnie
complète d'un gisement d'armes et de
terres à ce moment là leur jeep voir
leurs petits chars pas des gros chat
pouvait sortir ou alors si c'est pas le
cas parce que très souvent ces bateaux
est utilisé pour ravitailler et des
atolls des îles un peu lointaine et bien
facilement puisque vous avez directement
vous aviez des camions qui vous sert
thibout ne serait ce que 10 des
raccordements important en partie dans
un endroit où il ya pas de lui y'a pas
de porc donc est-ce que c'est dommage
qu'on ait perdu une capacité de la plage
âge là pour votre internaute la réponse
est clairement oui je suis d'accord avec
lui c'est dommage dans le ratio entre ce
qu'on a gagné avec les nouveaux bateaux
que remplacer les battre aller ce qu'on
a perdu je serais étonné sincèrement je
ne crois pas que globalement dans
l'addition globale on est perdu est-ce
que c'est dommage de plus pouvoir plage
et oui oui bien sûr que c'est dommage
mais il faut faire des choix est-ce
qu'on a ces deux bateaux la réponse est
non on n'en a pas assez parce que le
budget de la marine est suffisant la
réponse est non il n'est pas suffisant
alors saccagé devenu obsolète face à la
chine et l'inde est ce que pendant ce
temps notre matériel obsolète face à la
chine et russie quand on voit les
torpilles et hyper cavitation russe
leurs missiles père véloce l'armement
chinois qui crée une marine française
pratiquement c'est tout les 58 4 way
nouvelle marine française sous les 4
nouvelles maps à une française fric
avant alors que la marine française et
la 4e marine exactement au quand on voit
ça est ce qu'on n'a pas l'impression de
voir nos marins
est des cibles sur l'eau est-ce qu'on
n'a pas une armée qui simplement une
armée d'apparat est ce que on leur donne
un matériel qui n'est pas suffisamment
compétitifs déjà pour protéger leurs
équipages alors très clairement
nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui et la
france encore moins que les autres une
arme et d'apparat et d'ailleurs la
france est la seule nation occidentale
d'europe occidentale qu'ils sachent ce
qu'est la guerre je vais bien c'est la
seule nation parce que c'est la seule
qui la face en ce moment et tant qu'on
ne fait pas la guerre on ne sait pas ce
que c'est les autres pays européens ne
savent pas ce que c'est la guerre et
c'est assez énervant que dans cette
construction de l'union européenne ils
émettent des avis sur un sujet qu'ils ne
connaissent pas
donc la seule nation occidentale avec
les états unis si je prends mes une
définition plus large de l'occident
qu'ils sachent ce qu'est la guerre
aujourd'hui c'est la france est
aujourd'hui les armées françaises ne
sont pas désarmés d'apparat très
clairement en revanche en revanche dans
un monde qui se réarment de manière
colossale
vous avez un certain nombre de pays du
monde qui sont à plus de 100 %
d'augmentation
de la marine ou de leurs budgets de
défense effectivement cli qui abat la
chine
en méditerranée l'egypte l'algérie
la turquie pas tous 100% mais sont tous
à des taux très important et donc
certains sont à plus de 100% dans l'asie
du sud est donc l'ensemble du monde se
réarment et pas de quelques pourcents ya
au moins une dizaine de marines qui sont
à plus de 100 % d'augmentation la chine
comme vous le disiez à juste titre
marine française c'est la quatrième
année du monde la chine s'offrent tous
les quatre ans une nouvelle marine
française quelques beaux esprits peuvent
penser que c'est pour faire des revues
navales
très honnêtement c'est assez douteux et
en plus que ce soit la chine que ce soit
la russie ils sont présents soit dans
des mers qu'ils avaient abandonnés
pendant 20 à 30 ans c'est le cas de la
russie aujourd'hui il y a plus de sous
marins nucléaires d'attaqué soviétiques
et russes pardon en atlantique qu'il n'y
en a quasiment jamais eu à l'époque
soviétique
la chine est présente partout c'était
pas la capitale sanaa certains vous
disent jamais été le cas l' empire du
milieu rassurez-vous cela aussi c'est de
la foutaise rappelez vous ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure sur l'ordre mais hier
c'est l'ordre amelia qui régit le monde
la chine a été une grande puissance
navale la chine au xiiie siècle janier
scan il veut envahir le japon il envoie
4000 navire cent quarante mille hommes
c'est hallucinant au xiiie siècle et au
xvème siècle le début du xvème siècle la
chine passe son temps à lancer des
grandes expéditions navale dans tout
l'océan indien le fameux à meyrals zinc
et il part avec 300 navires et 30000
hommes ses 50 ans avant un pépère qui
s'appelle christophe colomb qui va
traverser l'atlantique avec trois
coquilles de noix et 90 bonhomme et on
nous en rabat encore les oreilles
aujourd'hui 1 3 coques de noix 90 p perd
c'est la geste de l'histoire de
l'humanité
cinquante ans après 300 navires trente
mille hommes
donc nous on est là à se gargariser
d'avoir été capable d'envoyer trop petit
bateau traverser l'atlantique
et si noah cinquante ans avant 300
navires 30 mais là il a fermé qui comme
ambassadeur d'un autre pays sur leurs
navires comme il s'appelait je sais pas
où est plus cultivé que moi je sais pas
mais en tout cas ils font des grandes
expéditions puis se trouve qu'en quinze
142 je me trompe peut-être un ou deux
ans près mais globalement à l'époque
c'est vraiment ça et décide d'ailleurs
il interdit la navigation hauturière et
10 ans se replie sur nous mêmes et ils
se replient pas sur eux mêmes parce que
l' empire du milieu et pacifique chez
pas quoi pas du tout ce qu'ils ont la
trouille un des hordes mongoles au nord
de chez eux donc là encore c'est bien le
dialogue mais lien qui leur impose de
faire ça ils ont compris leur erreur et
c'est fini ce temps dans et c'est fini
ce temps dans il ya des bateaux chinois
en méditerranée il ya des bateaux
chinois en méditerranée pas toute pêche
vous ai dit alors ici elle est votre
guerre il ya aussi les flottilles de
pêche dont sont celles bien qu'elles
sont des vrais flottis de guerre
regardez ce qui se passe en mer de chine
la chine a décidé que la mairie chine
c'était chez elle elle est allée bétonné
des petits attolou hier rien du tout
elle s'y installer le dit chez nous
maintenant vous venez pas et cette
liberté qui était absolument fondamental
pour le monde qu'il a la liberté de
navigation par tout ce que je rappelle
que la navigation commerciale c'est 90%
nos approvisionnements 90 % de ce que
nous consommons de ce que nous utilisons
pour vivre de ce que nous nous mangeons
ça vient c'est passer par la mer 90% je
me coupe si vous me permettez je viens
de l'avocat du diable est-ce que c'est
pas une réaction qu'on a provoqué chez
les chinois ont ces deux mois par les
états unis qui ont sécurisé le collier
de perles
c'est à dire que les chinois se sont vus
coincés depuis des années les américains
ont sécurisé le collier de perles et là
ils ont décidé maintenant ça suffit
alors évidemment c'est pas un jeu
solitaire et ces mêmes et donc ce que
vous dites n'est pas faux mais pas
complètement faux merci poule
les panneaux bêtement faut
d'abord ça s'inscrit dans une histoire
et dans la longue durée
et autant je ne porte pas sur mes
épaules la culpabilité d'un occident qui
devrait sans cesse se rouler par terre
sous prétexte qu'il a été colonialiste
que là encore à tous ceux qui pensent ça
je vous rappel c'est le dialogue mais
liens et c'est les plus forts qu'ils
gagnent et demain s'il est passé
panneaux les plus forts un tour
aujourd'hui ceux qui pleurnichent sur ce
méchant occident ils seront les premiers
à pleurnicher encore plus forts de ce
qui va nous arriver donc moi je porte
pas m'arrêter sur mes épaules la
culpabilité
initiale de l'occident néanmoins
néanmoins et d'ailleurs je vous ai
raconté cette histoire du tout à l'heure
enfin de davos 1997 il faut que nous
soyons conscients
de ces problématiques de ce qu'il en
reste des ventes et le n sauf que ses
parts dans leur racontant tout les jours
que nous avons été coupables qu'on
risque de préparer un avenir meilleur
bien au contraire si l'on met nous mêmes
les premiers alimenter les foyers de ce
qui va nous brûle et on va essayer s'est
hissé au secours au secours mais oui
bien sûr bien sûr il ya d'abord une
longue histoire
pire le traitement par les autos et en
particulier les britanniques 1 de la
chine au début du 20e siècle au 19e
siècle la guerre de la drogue et tout ça
ça c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas en être fier
c'est quelqu'un de l'allemand qu'on a
rendu on a rendu les chinois
complètement john key et ils n'ont pas
apprécié oui bien sûr et ça pour ça
gires n'oublions pas ça n'oublions pas
le passé je n'oublie pas mais justement
n'oubliez pas ou plutôt nous quand on se
remet dans le passé on a une lecture qui
est toujours bon donc n'oublions pas
tout cela donc d'abord il ya un passé
ensuite il y avait un passé lointain
ensuite effectivement un passé récent et
est ce que vous abordez avec de la mer
de chine et la réaction américaine les
réactions chinoises en mêlant action et
les chinoises aux américaines
le problème aujourd'hui le problème
aujourd'hui sans le savoir et distribue
les bons et mauvais points mais le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez
un pays qui inscrit son action dans une
vision globale du monde c'est la chine
est un pays enfin ce qui aujourd'hui
très clairement n'a plus qu'une vision
ou des visions régional du monde ce sont
les états unis et ça c'est un vrai
problème c'est un vrai problème parce
que c'est l'histoire ainsi les leçons de
la faire des sous marins australiens et
de la france
ah oui du contrat du contrat hocus et
donc j'en profite ça c'est une
typiquement de la part des états unis
des anglo saxons général mais des états
unis puis ce sont les australiens là
dessus ne sont que les les valets des
américains ça procède typiquement d'une
vision régionale et pas d'une vision
globale son camp face les chinois ils
ont une vision globale du monde et ils
ont raison
question internet canton vaud l'attitude
hostile des usa à l'encontre de notre
nation quelles alliances louis dans
l'ordre mondial qui vient
je ne pense pas que les américains
soient hostiles à notre nation gauchy
sur la tête alors oui mais c'est les
conséquences c'est pas les conséquences
d'une hostilité conceptuel ce sont les
conséquences justement d'une vision
ou plutôt de l'addition de vision
régionale et non pas d'une vision
globale du monde donc on prend pas en
compte toutes les choses au le se dire
dans une vision globale du monde c'est
pas mal d'avoir la france comme allié
dans le pacifique ont saisi dans une
vision régionale où on ne veut
développer et défendre que nos intérêts
on se dit on en a rien à se moque de la
france mais c'est à vision globale du
monde c'est pas très intelligent ça
c'est la même chose et la deuxième chose
mais vous allez croire que je suis je
fais une fixette et j'en suis obsédée
j'en suis pas obsédé mais c'est la
lecture du monde c'est un autre exemple
du dialogue millions
je suis le plus fort pense oncle sam
donc je fais ce que je veux et quand -
lecture du monde et faussent pas bonne
en particulier parce que les régionales
et pas globale et bien je fais des
erreurs et donc éventuellement jeu la
france ne m'intéresse pas
c'est le résultat de cette dialogue mais
lien qui régit le monde et de cette
vision régionale des états unis qui
aujourd'hui un font des erreurs parce
dans la proche d'une problématique
leur vision n'est pas suffisamment
globale et générale et 2 par là même ils
laissent des espaces lacunaire auxquels
ils ne s'intéressent plus et dans lequel
les autres s'engouffre et c'est ce que
fait la chine c'est ce que fait erdogan
c'est ce que font tous ces types là
aujourd'hui et c'est ce que fait avec un
bleu pour le coup et là encore c'est
vraiment pas n'y voyez pas de ma part
une défense du pépère mais ce que fait
avec maestria poutine poutine au moins
un truc qu'on peut lui reconnaître c'est
qu'il a inscrit sa vision du monde et
son action dans la durée dans la durée
dans une vision globale
je répète la question quand on voit
l'attitude hostile des usa l'encontre de
la nation
quelles alliances nouées dans l'ordre
mondial qui vient jeu et là aussi le
répète ce que j'ai déjà dit je ne vois
pas d'issue pour nous autres que dans
une construction intelligente de l'union
européenne ça c'est pour la chose
deuxièmement ensuite à lancer dès
maintenant par la france contenu il a
aussi de ce que je disais tout à l'heure
de son rôle particulier non pas de sa
toute-puissance de ne sont recrutés
effectivement et pour la france
maintenant et au service de l'europe
dans la durée bien évidemment nous avons
des grands alliés à trouver et pour moi
ya évidemment est clairement l'inde il
ya évidemment est clairement le japon il
ya peu de temps encore je vous aurais
dit à l'australie aps mais maintenant
c'est grillé pour un certain temps on
fait pour faire confiance et l'australie
nous faille valises comme on peut à
l'heure actuelle encore faire confiance
ou files qu'est ce que les failles baïse
jeu je pense que
healy a pour longtemps encore
un nombrilisme anglo saxons
sous
la houlette
américaine et avec en particulier des
anglais qui pour des tas de mauvaises
raisons
moi je regrette infiniment alors départ
de l'europe parce que il nous était
nécessaire mais pour des tas de
mauvaises raisons ont toujours
n'ont toujours pas compris leur intérêt
européen et ont toujours décidé de jouer
mais sans voir que ils n'étaient devenus
que la dernière roue du carrosse
la donne américaine mais à mon avis à
tort et mon avis ils vont le regretter
de la même manière je pense que les à
partir de cette histoire de sumatra de
sous marins l'australie va le payer très
cher j'ai d'abord leurs sous marins qui
va se passer beaucoup de temps avant
qu'ils les aient voulait louis ils vont
strictement rien gagné industriellement
économiquement et technologiquement ils
vont se retrouver avec des sous marins à
uranium enrichi alors que les
sous-marins français sont réunis en bas
prix ça veut dire quoi demeure très
clair c'est qu'avec que le costume
combustible nucléaire un sous marin
nucléaire français vous ne pouvez pas
fabriquer une bombe avec le combustible
nucléaire d'un sous-marin à la mode
américaine vous pouvez fabriquer une
bombe je suis toujours sidérée que les
écologistes australiens qui sont quand
même assez rapide pour crier contre
l'unique les rochers pas quoi ce soit
toujours pas réveillé donc à mon avis
les australiens ils sont devenus les
valets des américains pour très
longtemps et sans aucun gain pour eux
sans aucun gain pour eux mais bon c'est
leur problème c'est pas bien donc pour
revenir à votre question c'est
évidemment une alliance est une
construction enfin plus intelligente et
plus efficace de l'union européenne en
se posant les bonnes questions les
bonnes questions et puis c'est des
partenariats intelligents avec des vrais
partenaires qui ont tout à craindre de
la chine d'une part les russes mais
évidemment les russes évidemment les
russes je pense que depuis 30 ans 20
depuis la chute du mur de berlin des
occidentaux mais les américains le 1er
mai les occidentaux et nous européens on
aurait pu être un peu plus un peu plus
pertinents on joue mal la carte russe et
là encore ce coloris ou 6 7 mai et là
encore c'est à ce non pas pour créditer
poutine de quoi que ce soit mais bien
sûr qu'on joue ma de la carte est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la chine
comme en réaction aux attitudes
américaine mais c'est encore plus vrai
pour la russie et pour les réactions
occidentales en général et américaine en
particulier c'est n'importe quoi mais la
même manière l'iran regardez ce qui
s'est passé l'iran saasenheim avec
l'iran vous savez de plus social et puis
là discours de bush ville un discours de
bush qui les place sur l' axe du mal
c'est un mot une expression des humains
c'est bien ce qui s'est passé dans cette
histoire et contraindre nous non mais
même avant sa regroupant 1 bush près par
bush fils prépare son discours sur
l'état de l'union le grand discours
annuel du président américain
il a tous ses conseillers autour de lui
allez vivre en tout cas ses conseillers
certains des meilleurs étaient là mais
ils se sont tus et on lit la première
copie du discours est là les conseillers
comme
les conseillers comme dix ministres
présidente s'est pas assez saignant
doux quelqu'un suggère l'histoire de lax
du mal tout ça avant mais l'iran
condoleeza rice qui est donc la
secrétaire d'état américaine hélas elle
sait que c'est une énorme bêtise pour un
nombre de raisons qu'il procède tout ça
j'en sais rien je n'étais pas de son
agenda personnel ne sais quoi elle se
tait elle elle sait que c'est une bêtise
peut se taire et les conseillers comme
l'emportent çà çà çà c'est une sorte
d'écho à votre question tout à l'heure
sur les médias les conseillers comme
l'emportent et donc bouge fait un
discours où il parle de l'ex du mal où
il refoule la russie l'iran et tout ça
début des emmerdes début de l'an berne
dramatique c'est traumatique c'est ce
même bush qui ont lu par prometic au
moyen-orient il finit par dire tu avais
je comprends rien là vous me parlez de
shit de sunnites je croyais qu'ils
étaient tous musulmans
c'est sûr quand votre lecture du monde
on revient la culture que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure et la capacité à penser
autrement et tout ça c'est fondamental
tous les leaders que ce soit ceux du
monde géopolitique que soient les
leaders de la société civile et des
entreprises on ne peut pas être un grand
leader si on ne développe pas et on ne
cultive pas celle qu'elle veut dire sa
propre culture tous les jours il ya la
culture politique y est les cultures
tout ça
on a un chef des armées qui est très
cultivé c1 c'est un poète dans son âme
et qu'elle porte quel regard vous portez
sur le président de la république
alors là on a évoqué tout à l'heure le
droit de réserve mutine oui on a évoqué
tout à l'heure le droit de réserve vous
ai bien qu'un officier général
sincèrement je suis obligé de vous poser
le vrai bien sûr non mais vous avez tout
à fait le rôle de la caisse de la poser
exactement et je vais juste vous
rappeler que il me semble avoir été s'il
lit assez libre dans mon ton depuis le
début notre entretien
je considère que le devoir de réserve un
officier général donc hic continue même
quantité d'ailleurs ainsi général il
n'est pas la retraite ont dit qu'ils
leur deuxième section ski à tout le
monde peut être appelé donc je considère
que là pour le coup même si je ne suis
plus un officier général active je n'ai
pas à formuler de jugement sur le
présent dans la république
je dirais néanmoins que 1
il a des idées européennes ont
personnellement je suis assez proche
d'eux
jeu on peut se poser des questions sur
ce de manière générale qui sont autour
de lui
il est directeur de
son entourage
mais ce que il a autour de lui ce qu'il
faut pour mener la tâche difficile qui
l'a amené trois dans la sphère du que
vides qui secoue ce pays
je trouve que lui faire des reproches et
là je suis pas en train de donner des
satisfecit mais je trouve que lui faire
des reproches
c'est pas très honnête parce que
sincèrement qui sait exactement ce qu'il
faut faire avec déjà un corps
scientifique qui vous dit tout et son
contraire à tout moment je pense que
c'est pas facile
est-ce que nous sommes sur ce sujet là
bien gérée en ce moment sincèrement
est-ce qu'on pourrait être mieux géré et
j'en sais rien donc là dessus moi j'ai
pas de procès à lui faire et d'une
manière générale je trouve que l'on
gagnerait tous à ce que la fonction
présidentielle soient plus respectés
quel que soit l'image où le jugement
qu'on a sur l'homme ou la femme qui la
porte c'est compliqué avec un président
qui dit kiki aux maires de certaines
personnes je suis pas sûr je suis même
sûr de cancer pour le coup que ce soit
l'une de ses expressions les plus à
droite oui
je pense que dd manière générale et ça
ça dépasse ce qu'il a pu dire là et à
les médailles on peut comprendre un
moment donné un homme quelle que soit sa
fonction
se lâche un petit peu je pense que le
feu nucléaire compliqué comme à nourrir
oui mais ça c'est un autre sujet mais je
pense que
même si on n'est pas d'accord
moi je pense que les gens qui refusent
de se faire vacciner
il ya deux catégories il y a certains
c'est par crétinisme et dogmatisme et
d'autres c'est avec des vraies raisons
quelle que soit la raison que ce soit
leur crétinisme leur dogmatisme ou des
vraies raisons je pense que tout citoyen
doit être respectée que c'est le rôle de
ceux qui nous gouvernent de respecter
tout le monde s'il fallait
décréter des brevets de citoyenneté sur
le crétinisme
on épure est rapidement le nombre de
citoyens s politique et la classe
politique aussi donc je pense que tout
citoyen je pense que tout individu
doit être respectée et protégée
quel qu'il soit et d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus je pense que c'est un domaine où on
se trompe complètement dans la défense
des soi-disant minorité je pense qu'il
est qu'il n'est d'abord qu'il est
d'abord médecin et qui en plus il n'est
pas efficace de protéger quelqu'un pour
ce qu'il est je pense qu'il faut
protéger tout individu quel qu'il soit
et c'est une différence majeure parce
que quand on commence à protéger les
gens soit disant parce qu'ils ont si ou
ça
on fait des classifications ont fait des
citoyens des sous citoyens il y en a que
vous avez votre critique et d'autres que
vous avez pas le droit et pourquoi
pourquoi on a le droit de critiquer
un tel alors qu'on n'a pas le droit de
critiquer un tel je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux et puis
deuxièmement on observe bien c'est pas
efficace c'est pas efficace donc moi je
suis convaincu que cette idée mais qui
l'idée prégnante qu'il est majeur que il
faut protéger des gens particulier
mérité pour ce qu'elles sont je pense
que c'est une idée mauvaise tange rezé
contre objectif et je suis convaincu que
le seul credo qui tienne c'est de dire
il faut protéger tout individu quel
qu'il soit quel qu'il soit hélas on est
dans une logique inversée à mon avis
c'est très grave et donc je pense que
tout le monde doit être protégé tout le
monde doit être protégée à l'air d'une
dodge
si je vous parle de la crise du coït si
je vous dit vous n'avez pas anticipé
vous vous êtes fait surprendre donc vous
avez perdu ça vous fait penser à quoi
je pense que la première tic de
l'anticipation qui cette phrase
je sais pas
c'est un grand militaire française c'est
qui j'ai un trou de mémoire comme vous
c'est ok non ça va
c'est à la fois vrai
et est pas complètement
on ne peut pas anticiper tout ce qui
nous arrivera c'est pas vrai sur les
épidémies les pandémies c'est fou non
mais je parle en général
j'ai pas dit qu'on pouvait rien anticipé
je dis qu'on peut pas tout anticiper et
donc
la problématique n'est pas d'être
capable de tout anticiper
la problématique
vous dire et après vous jouez sur les
mots et tout dépend de la définition
qu'on donne aux mots anticiper et pour
moi on va prévoir tout ce qui va se
passer et s'il ya un domaine qui est
parti mon vrai pour cela c'est bien la
guerre peut pas prévoir ce que c'est en
revanche
il faut sans cesse se prépare et se met
dans une posture qui va nous permettre
de réagir le plus vite possible
pour moi c'est ça qui est fondamentale
et plus vous aurez essayé d'imaginer ce
qui pourrait se passer
plus vous aurez essayé de comprendre le
monde et ses évolutions possibles plus
vous vous serez dit tiens on croit je
dis cela mais que se passera-t-il si en
fait c'est l inverse je pense que c'est
ça qui va arriver et en fait comment je
me projette dans une situation
finalement c'est exactement l'inversé
qui va se passer plus on est capable de
faire seul en
plus le jour j quand la crise arrive
plus ou moins prévu plus on sait réagir
vite et donc je pense que l'enjeu n'est
pas sur la capacité à avoir tout prévu
c'est impossible mais sur notre capacité
à réagir le plus vite possible je donne
un exemple très simple
qu'on dise que ce que c'est pas des
exemples d'ailleurs route dont je suis
un spécialiste mais qu'en dise à un
moment donné pour un nombre de raisons
économiques logistiques
on va plus stocker de masques en france
parce qu'on croit que ce sera plus utile
d'en avoir après tout pourquoi pas et
donc c'est pas de prendre une telle
décision qui me choque ce qui me choque
c'est qu'on se dise pas quand on décide
d'arrêter d'avoir des masques qu'on se
dise pape on met en place un système qui
fait que si on s'est trompé on sera
capable de refaire de nouveau très vite
on s'est trompés nous on continue à
faire des délits c'est magnifique ma
phrase exacte saison n'a le droit de
perdre mais pas de se faire surprendre
en fait surprendre on ait réagi comme
des bleus a collé des affichettes
inquiète alors moi je moi j'avais reçoit
deux phrases et ensuite on m'a dit oh là
là l'armée l'armée il faut me faire des
lits des hôpitaux de campagne 30 parking
je trouve ça c'est du n'importe quoi je
suis bien d'accord que la situation de
l'hôpital après deux ans de crise soit
celle qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est
incompréhensible pour moi c'est
incompréhensible donc je suis pas
spécialiste sujet donc je vais pas moi
même comme tout ces faux experts vous
dire ce qu'il faudrait faire yakafocon
mai mais néanmoins le citoyen que je
suis je trouve ça un conte prince et je
renverse de phrase je suis absolument
pas d'accord avec votre phrase pour moi
c'est pas on a droit de perdre mais pas
de se faire surprendre pour moi c'est on
peut se faire surprendre n'en a pas le
droit de perdre et en tout cas le
militaire que je suis l'officier général
j'ai suivi d'un jeu je vous dis on peut
se faire surprendre et personnes qui de
près ou de loin à approcher la guerre
peut imaginer qu'on peut jamais se faire
surprendre d'avoir vraiment pensé ça
c'est débile mais moi je vous dis on
peut se faire surprendre mais on n'a pas
le reperdre le renseignement français il
en est où maintenant
le renseignement militaire
on va pas fait un renseignement français
en faire le renseignement militaire il
en est où
1 je ne suis pas un spécialiste cette
question mais je réponds pas ça pour
fuir votre réponse ou simplement pour
bien dire à tout le monde en général ne
fuit pas non d'abord un amiral ne fuit
pas
mais simplement je précise que voilà je
vais vous apporter une réponse dans un
champ qui n'est pas celui que je connais
de mieux
leur enseignement en général est
d'autant plus compliquée que la
complexité du monde
c'est profondément accrue vous bien que
vous voyez bien que pour rester dans le
domaine stratégique et géopolitique
le monde de la guerre froide était un
monde dangereux
compliqué mais pas complexe mais pas
complexe
et que donc la problématique du
renseignement dans ce monde là
est ce qu'on faisait bien ce qu'on
faisait pas bien j'en sais rien mais
elle affronter une situation qui n'était
pas complexe nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un monde qui est infiniment plus
complexe avec l'une logiciels alors
infiniment plus dangereux
et avec probablement de la part à tous
une capacité d'évolution pas assez
rapide absolument et d'autre part même
si je suis pas obsédé je fais pas partie
de ceux qui pensent que les réponses
sont toujours dans les moyens sam aurait
pu d'ailleurs comment ça c'est pas vrai
ça n'est pas toujours une affaire de
moyens c'est faux mais néanmoins
néanmoins ya un certain nombre de sujets
pour lequel il faut malgré tout un
certain nombre de choses concrètes et
incarner point man et là-dessus
j'entends des choses sidérant lorsque je
sais que je suis un vieux monsieur on
vous avait invité un amiral à la
retraite donc par définition oui c'est
un vieux monsieur néanmoins garnett
depuis un an sa tournée vote est un peu
voir le nombre de chevaux blancs et
canon mais ça ne serait pas les moins
bons néanmoins même si c'est pas de
teinture mais évidemment à quelle idée
même si je suis un vieux monsieur je
suis
j'ai 60 ans vieux mais pas bon pour
certains c'est vrai quand j'étais à
l'école navale les lieutenants vaisseau
qui était le chef d'escouade
fixer les jeunes ces temps où il était
super vieux un amiral comme j'étais le
canal on n'imaginait même pas ce que
c'était alors vous pensez un amiral à la
retraite je sais même pas si sûr notre
galaxie bon même si je suis un vieux
monsieur ne vous en déplaise je suis
malgré tout pas rentrer dans l'armée
ilit a si longtemps quand je suis rentré
dans l'armée en 1983 très exactement
c'est l'année où je suis rentrée à
l'école navale le pourcentage de notre
pib consacré au budget de défense
c'était trois et demi pour cent
well 3,8 en données
j'ai pas le souvenir
et le budget par exemple de l'éducation
nationale était derrière et assez loin
derrière le budget de la défense
aujourd'hui c'est totalement inversée et
avec un pour ça je suis pas choqué que
le budget des cas nationale soit plus
important que celui la défense c'est
parce que j'entends des lionceaux et du
cube ont fait germer un
j'ai pas le souvenir que l'éducation
nationale marchait moins bien en
1983 que en 2022 et pourtant elle avait
beaucoup plus d'élèves
et donc quand aujourd'hui on nous
raconte puisque c'est un engagement que
les pays occidentaux sont censés avoir
pris qu'il faut remonter le budget de
défense à 2% du pib et qu'on nous dit
c'est impossible je le lis mais vous
foot ma gueule
c'est quoi cette hypocrisie en
1983 c'était trois nuits pour cent et la
société l'état fonctionnait mieux
qu'aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui vous me
dites qu'on peut pas remonter à 2% alors
qu'on est dans un monde infiniment plus
complexe et plus dangereux
qu'il ya 50 ans donc il ya un problème
il ya un vrai problème donc oui même si
je ne fais pas parti c'est pas ma vision
du monde de ceux qui pensent que tout
est dans les moyens d'ailleurs
l'éducation nationale en est un bon
exemple c'est vraiment pas un problème
de moyens leur budget augmenter alors
qu'ils ont beaucoup moins d'élèves et ça
marche beaucoup moins bien c'est pas une
affaire de moyens mais néanmoins
néanmoins surtout quand derrière les
ordinations il ya les matériels ya des
technologies bien sûr que les moyens ça
compte un peu et que l'on devrait se
poser des menaces entre deux questions
sur les moyens qu'on alloue un certain
nombre de fonctions régaliennes celle de
la justice - font partie de sa future
s'il est un se consacrait plus à ces
grandes fonctions régaliennes peut-être
qu'il utiliserait un peu mais ces moyens
que ça marcherait un peu mieux même si
là encore toute la réponse n'est pas là
dedans mais donc dans un monde
infiniment plus complexe beaucoup plus
dangereux dont on a du mal à dans lequel
on a du mal à quitter nos anciens
schémas nos anciennes organisations et
avec des moyens qui sont pas suffisants
ouais on peut se poser des questions sur
notre efficacité ouais ça c'est sûr mais
là encore c'est pas un sujet dont je
suis un grand spécialiste
je vous fait recoudre
question internet que pense-t-il de
l'adage si vis pacem para un vélo mais
je pense que comme la majorité des
adages surtout lorsqu'ils viennent
d'aussi loin ils sont évidemment
totalement plein de bon sens plein de
bon sens
si nous ne sommes pas capables de nous
défendre
1 parce que nous avons pas cet esprit de
défense que vous évoquez vos même tout à
l'heure et on peut se poser des vraies
questions pour savoir si on l'a cet
esprit de défense jeudi a chuté elle
essaie de faire un peu de boulot quand
même
les jeunes de l'ime dn font du beau
boulot passez un coup que j'ai quelques
interrogations sur lle hdn dans son
ensemble mais j'ai une certitude c'est
que les jeunes de lits h c'est vachement
bien ça j'en suis absolument convaincu
vous avez des questions sur les
azuréennes
je me pose des vraies questions sur et
là aussi c'est un écho avec ce que vous
avez déjà évoqué plusieurs fois sur un
système qui quand même globalement
depuis soixante dix ans n'a pas vraiment
évolué
dans un monde qui effectivement on n'a
pas du tout évolué de son côté est ce
que ce serait vraiment cohérent
donc est ce que aujourd'hui mail encore
je ne suis pas en charge ça et donc la
critique est aisée mais je suis
complètement acquis à l'idée de lire
shônen ça je suis mais compétent à qui
la façon dont on le fait
je vais dire simplement que j'ai des
interrogations
néanmoins ces deux cinquièmes
intéressant les jeunes lire je trouve ça
super absolument là dessus sans
restriction donc cet esprit de défense
est ce que vraiment nous l'avons nous en
sommes nous par rapport cette fameuse
phrase qu'on attendait beaucoup plus à
ma génération si vous savez plutôt rouge
que mort
moi c'est pas ma philosophie de la vie
donc il ya une vraie question sur l'état
de défense et donc c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut travailler ça évidemment un
rapport avec l'idée que nous faisons la
nation que je trouve que dans ce domaine
aujourd'hui sur la nation on entend
beaucoup de carabistouilles débile
et je trouve qu'on gagnerait tous à
relire ce que raconte ronan je vois pas
en quoi le discours sur la nation de
romans à aurait changé et il dit quoi
pour simplifier c'est très intéressant
ce qui dit heureusement il dit la nation
c'est pas une affaire de peuples c'est
pas une photographie c'est pas une
affaire de race c'est pas une affaire de
culture c'est très intéressante mais la
sphère de langues il dit c'est deux
choses
c'est accepter un héritage commun
quelle que soit la façon dont on accepte
et c'est un une volonté de faire quelque
chose ensemble ouais ouais bah moi moi
moi je trouve ça toujours d'actualité
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas
aujourd'hui
il ya une vraie question sur l'esprit de
défense et puis derrière dans un monde
où on a des opposants potentiels
qui se réarme a plus de sens pour son
augmentation de leur budget sur de
longues années à venir bout est le plus
beau le plus intelligent si vous êtes
tout nu dans le désert à face à des
canons moderne vous gagnez a pas la
guerre
et dans ce dialogue mais lien qui est
l'ordre du monde qui régit le monde dans
un occident qui est encore très riche
face à des pays autour de nous qui ne
sont pas forcément
dans un occident qui a encore les pieds
au sec face et des pays dont par
centaines de milliers voire millions la
population vont être chassés de chez eux
par la montée des eaux
évacuée et pas que
le stress hydrique c'est pas que la
montée des eaux est
exactement ce que fait erdogan
aujourd'hui en turquie 1 à l'encontre de
la syrie et tous les pays du proche et
du moyen orient et nous on dit rien et
on se dit on les garde dans l'otan ceux
des amis on n'ose rien leur dire vos
copains du quai d'orsay son
avocat par des quais dans le
jeu c'est bien phu taquine
donc toutes ces raisons là sans que si
on n'est pas capable d'être fort il
faudra pas pleurer on aura la guerre et
ont une faible c'est bien on aura la
guerre et on la paie et on la perd brave
s'est passé ce vieil adage c'est les
périodes difficiles font des hommes
forts il est pilote face ils font des
hommes faibles c'est ça c'est pas
complètement faux s'est pas totalement
vrai il faut pas désespérer non plus
rappelez vous ce que je disais sur mon
credo personnel sur les clairières moi
je crois qu'il ya des clairières et donc
il ya partout dans le monde et à tous
les niveaux et tous les étages et dans
toutes les strates et tous les endroits
des hommes et des femmes de bonne
volonté mais c'est derrière c'est la
forêt autour c'est des clients dire
qu'il faut faire ou ce et des poches de
résistance
ce sont des clairières dont certaines
doivent déjà être des poches de
résistance et avec l'espoir qu'elles
n'auront pas tout à se transformer en
poche de résistance c'est néanmoins un
scénario qui n'est pas à exclure
question internet
pourquoi à l'école de guerre il y a
toujours environ le même pour son simple
pourcentage de saint cyrien 80% des mii
à 19% dorsaz 1% alors que la sélection
est anonyme parce que la nature est bien
faite par l'interrogation c'est ça la
sélection ibérique pour l'interrogation
alors ces chiffres sont sont ne sont que
partiellement vrai
ils sont que partiellement vrai en
particulier ils le sont en partie ils ne
sont pas pour la marine pour une raison
très clair les offres saas à plusieurs
ça s'appelle les offices au contrat
depuis toujours dans la marine tout le
monde peut passer le concours de l'école
de guerre et il n'y a aucune prime à
aucune catégorie
jusqu'il ya peu de temps
c'est en train de changer partiellement
pour la mater pas encore pour la mer
mais je ne doute pas que ça change alia
mens là encore quand c'est un à meyrals
qui dit ça il peut être suspect mais il
se trouve que là dessus c'est la marine
qui a raison il se trouve que dans
l'armée terre et dans l'armée d'air
jusqu'à il ya peu de temps si vous
n'étiez pas issu de saint cyr
ou de le mée à mes côtés d'une façon
vous ne pouviez pas passer le concours
vous ne pouviez pas se passer donc ont
donc s'adonner ces chiffres juste par
construction
les autres ne pouvaient pas passer le
concours c'est évidemment une erreur et
c'est une erreur que la marine n'a
jamais fait et donc là dessus sur ce
sujet là la marine a évidemment raison
ayant dit cela
je veux me contenter de à prendre pour
la marine puisque là le jeu est
complètement libre il n'y a aucune prime
quelqu'un qui a fait les cons à mal
comme moi c'est ce qu'on appelle un
bordage ya zéro primo board h
au concours de l'école de guerre il se
trouve que alors que le jeu est libre
vous avez toujours je sais pas les
chiffres exacts mais vous avez toujours
une majorité
de gens qui sont ici des connaît mal à
l'écolo guerre parce que pour l'instant
le système de recrutement français celui
des grandes écoles qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure il a des inconvénients on en a
parlé mais il a aussi un septembre
davantage et c'est un système qui pour
l'instant continue à recruter des
garçons et des filles à 18 ans de grande
qualité
et que donc on retrouve ensuite le
concours de l'école de guerre parce que
on sait pas totalement planté dans le
recrutement initial
le jour où ce niveau ce pourcentage le
board h à l'école de guerre basculerait
complètement il faudra se poser des
questions
je peux vous dire que de toute façon il
va évoluer pour la marine assez vite
puisque depuis maintenant cinq ou six
ans la marraine recrue des officiers
sous contrat opérations qui sont des
gens dont qui sont pas passés par
l'école navale et à qui la marine offre
exactement les mêmes carrière et les
mêmes chances que les bordage et donc je
pense le père d'entre eux sortent aussi
le système des grandes écoles équivalent
je pense que assez vite
la population dos et c'est à l'école de
guerre pour la marine va augmenter en
pourcentage parce que le jeu est libre
et parce qu'on a créé un système de
recrutement quel équivalente celui les
cas là bas
en ce qui concerne la remettait l'armée
de l'air me suis là aussi je ne tiens
pas à critiquer parce que parce que ce
n'est pas mon armée que je trouve pas ça
les gars en plus j'étais le directeur à
la fin de la guerre des gaules guerre et
qui de loin l'unité interarmées la plus
emblématique des armées les hongrois
d'ailleurs si je peux me permettre de
rajouter en tant que civil c'est
l'endroit où j'ai vu le plus de liberté
pendant les débats
donc si la communauté veut assister au
débat qui à l'école de guerre il faut
fureter un petit peu pour avoir leur
date c'est un endroit où les militaires
protègent les questions des civils alors
c'est facile aujourd'hui d'y rentrer
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que je
ne sais pas ce que c'est moi qui ai pris
cette décision aujourd'hui et l'écolo
guerre est ouvert à des auditeurs c'est
bidon qui lie à temps la promo d'école
guerre 60 auditeurs civile c'est
beaucoup il ya 180 officiers français de
toute armée soixante dix neuf civils
wake c'est un ratio qui est intéressant
mon premier commentaire il ya un
pourcentage important de dieter civile à
l'école de guerre et deuxième
commentaire c'est qu'il y ait un nombre
de deux
deux conférences et en particulier celle
qui s'appelle les conférences de l'école
guerre le titre pas très original mais
il est simple ces conférences sont des
conférences certes pour les officiers de
la promo mais qui sont ouvertes aux
civils et là tout le monde pas seulement
aux auditeurs côté l'ex est sélectionnée
pour faire partie de la promo et donc
c'est un lieu où on peut aller d'un lieu
des changes c'est un lieu normalement de
liberté c'est un lieu où on apprend à
penser autrement et c'est un lieu où
l'esprit interarmées va atteindre son
apogée après risquent de s'éroder mais
au moins on peut espérer qu'elle est
conne et alleo donc vous ne me ferez pas
critiquer les lézards mais qui ne sont
pas la mienne néanmoins sur ce sujet
c'est un veau général et aimer sur ce
sujet du concours à l'école de guerre je
pense que et je dirai simplement comme
ça que la même terre qui est en train de
changer et l'armée de l'air sont sont en
retard par rapport à la marine et je ne
vois aucune raison valable de ne pas
ouvrir le concours de l'école guerra
tous les officiers quelle que soit leur
origine et c'est ce que fait la marine
il n'y a aucune raison ensuite de mettre
des primes à telle ou telle catégorie
ccc c'est idiot ils ont toujours aussi
prétention armée de l'air
je je je
je
vous savez on dit souvent
mais alors bien que ce soit faux on dit
souvent cela des marins c'est
profondément injuste mais c'est souvent
c'est profondément la joie ils sont
cools respectueux toujours servir il
faut bien comprendre il est normal il
est sain il est bon ça c'est quelque
chose que le pouvoir politique je parle
pas de l'actuelle je parle vraiment du
pouvoir politique en général a beaucoup
de mal à comprendre
il est normal que ces trois armées et
donc leurs officiers leurs militaires en
général mais les officiers en
particulier et des cultures très
différentes c'est complètement normal
c'est pas normal c'est même nécessaire
je voulais illustrer d'un meurtre c'est
un truc que j'ai mis longtemps à
comprendre je vais découvrir vraiment
que quand j'étais à l'école de guerre
donc je pars très fier de moi j'aurais
pu le pij et plus vite mais j'ai
longtemps justement trouvé en
particulier que les 13 le mariage était
analysée avec un peu de recul je vais le
dire comme ça les ce qu'on appelle les
traditions dans l'armée de terre j'avoue
que je comprenais pas toujours
ok ils t'ont qui prétendent que c'est
pour la cohésion me dire c'est bizarre
ce mot de cohésion que les militaires
amateurs utilisent tout le temps les
marins l'utilisent pas c'est très
bizarre et donc leurs traditions autour
de ça moi je crois bien en fait j'avais
tort j'avais tort ai je voulu illustrer
ne pas voir laisser nous l'expliqué de
man et après ça
son simple
désir de survie
d'un marin
le pousse naturellement sur un bateau à
être vertueux à se mettre au service de
tout l'équipage parce qui comprend tout
seul même s'il n'est pas malin et
comprend tout seul que s'il ne fait pas
ça
il va y passer donc son instinct de
survie
le pousse à être vertueux est au service
de son équipage
naturellement sans effort qu'il soit
intelligent
stupide
l'instinct de survie d'un fantassin dans
sa tranchée qui doit monter à l'assaut
son instinct de survie je parle du mec
normal
son instinct de survie va jamais le
pousser à sortir de la tranchée pour
monter à l'assaut sont à 5 survie il va
le pousser soi à se terrer au fond de la
tranchée soit contraire à partir de
l'autre côté son instinct de survie et
donc l'armée de terre très
intelligemment a mis en place depuis des
siècles
ce qu'on appelle ses traditions pour
prendre en compte cette réalité
parce que votre instinct de survie au
fond d'une tranchée il vous pousse pas à
monter à l'assaut en tout cas le mec
normal un fou peut-être mais sauf que le
fantassin fou c'est pas intéressant donc
l'instinct de survie
un homme le pouce est naturellement
vertueux dans la marine
va devoir être combattu dans l'armée de
terre l'armée de l'air c'est encore une
autre problématique parce que d'abord
est ce que je veux dire est absolument
pas une critique c'est juste un constat
dans l'armée de l'air ceux qui risquent
leur vie c'est une toute petite minorité
c'est les pilotes est en tout cas les
équipages embarqués et dans la majorité
des cas en plus ils sont tous seuls dans
leurs avions et donc vous voyez bien que
là vous êtes encore dans une logique qui
est complètement différente et donc ces
trois logiques différentes quand vous
partez du simple fait incontestable de
l'instinct de survie
pousse ses armes et à avoir à développer
à construire des cultures différentes
et la réponse
extrêmement noble et intelligente que
l'armée de terre a apporté à cette
problématique c'est ce que l'on
remettait rappelle ses traditions et un
marin et comprend pas ça parce que parce
que tant qu'il n'a pas analysé ce qui
n'en a pas besoin
et donc quand il entend parler de
cohésion lui qui est naturellement dans
son esprit d'équipage il dit mais c'est
pourquoi ils font ça c'est débile quand
vous réfléchi deux secondes vous le
comprenez
est ce que ça veut dire que les uns et
les autres ensuite vivre leur culture
comme il faut je sais pas quoi est ce qu
ils ont tous compris c'est un autre
débat mais en tout cas c'est
profondément normal et ces différences
sont profondément nécessaire et analyser
ces différences entre les armées comme
étant des différences contre-productive
faut qu'elles bossent ensemble c'est une
grave erreur c'est une grave erreur
c'est une erreur qu hélas trop souvent
ceux qui sont à l'extérieur et ceux qui
nous gouvernent fond mais c'est normal
que nous soyons différents le jour on ne
sera pas
construit par ces différences
culturelles on le payera très cher vous
avez vu un bol d'eau de mer j'ai bu un
boulot de merde oui vous savez vous
connaissez les pourquoi j'ai dû boire un
bol mère pour lui c'est sûr que c'était
pas pour vous touristes 1 alors ça l'a
déclenché mais lorsque on est baptisé
sur les sauts sur les sur les sous
marins vous avez un ami imaginaire
c'est à dire vous croyez en dieu ah
pardon ah oui bien sûr que je suis a
bien fait bien sûr je suis je suis
catholique
c'est extrêmement important dans ma vie
et
suis-je un bon chrétien notre question
mais attends qu à cet important et je
suis profondément croyant absolument et
je l'assumé je n'ai pas honte de lire
mais ce reviens je vois pas en quoi ma
question sur ce que je crois en dieu
partir du moment où vous aviez évoqué la
turista je sais pas quelle connexion
s'est fait notre esprit c'est pas
inintéressant il se trouve qu'on est
baptisé sur les sous-marins quand on est
un jeune soeur aînée comprend des
questions et on le rituel parce que
malgré tout même si on n'a pas autant de
traditions dans les tpo parce
qu'effectivement les raisons sont
différentes on doit boire un litre d'eau
de mer on doit boire une grande quantité
d'un va absolument dégueulasse et aussi
un peu de champagne et je vous confirme
bien que ce soit pas très élégant et et
alors que vous avez soi-disant invité un
poète dans votre émission c'est un c'est
un laxatif extrêmement performants
ont dit tout le temps que la guerre
c'est l'extension de la politique
c'est la poursuite c'est ce que dit
effectivement clausewitz et la poursuite
de la politique par d'autres moyens
c'est en tout cas
complètement lié
est ce que c'est la poursuite de la
politique par d'autres moyens ou est-ce
que c'est considérer que c'est parce que
la politique a échoué on pourrait en
débattre très longtemps simplement et là
encore et pas seulement parce que c'est
une fixette si on a compris que le monde
était régi par l'ordre millien est
absolument on comprend bien que la
guerre est la politique sont infiniment
liés que la politique va bien souvent
généré la guerre dans cette trinité dont
parle clausewitz tout ça bien sûr et
bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est vous vous
venez de me permettre d'illustrer que le
monde est bien régi par l'ordre médias
question internet mais de voir mon
général pensez vous que l'arrivée de
l'intelligence artificielle rendre à
l'humain inopérant landes éventuel
conflit de haute intensité au vu de la
rapidité de prise de décisions dont sera
capable la machine versus lui mme
sarah très évidemment et ans quand je
dis ça je fais des lapalissades ou
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes ou de
monsieur jourdain sera évidemment un
impact majeur
est-ce que ça va remplacer totalement
l'esprit humain non pour au moins deux
raisons
la première qui est technique au
concrète c'est qu' il n'y a pas de
combat performant sans prise initiative
sans inventivité sans penser autrement
et l'intelligence artificielle ce que le
fédéral n'avait pas une critique c'en
est tout simplement une analyse
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
justement c'est pas penser autrement
c'est pas prendre l'initiative
et l'intelligence artificielle ne sera
jamais capable de se qui est le coeur de
la discipline contrairement à ce que les
gens croient qu est-ce que c'est la
discipline
l'expression la plus emblématique de la
discipline françois lecointre le disait
le précédent ses mains le disait très
souvent et il a complètement raison je
suis totalement d'accord il faut dire ce
que c'est pour mes chefs d'état major
des armées le grand patron des armées il
le rappeler souvent et je suis
infiniment d'accord et et moi aussi
lorsque j'étais à l'école gars je
passais on entend le rappeler
l'expression la plus emblématique de la
discipline pour un militaire c'est
l'initiative au combat
discipline c'est pas autre chose
on a eu notre image et pense que c'est
autre chose mais la discipline je vous
ne trouverez pas de meilleure définition
de la cip linke celle-là des
disciplines c'est l'initiative au combat
et bien l'initiative au combat c'est pas
un truc d'intelligence artificielle
et le penser autrement
une intelligence artificielle c'est ses
pensées très largement c'est balayer
plein de choses s'est additionné bien
chose bien sûr mais véritablement penser
autrement ben non justement s'est passé
à l'intelligence artificielle donc oui
ça va avoir un impact très important
pour le bien pour le pire je sais pas
encore et comme tout vent et pour ne pas
dire toujours dans la condition humaine
certainement de temps en temps pour le
bien est certainement et là dedans pour
le pire mais ça ne remplacera pas
complètement l'homme ne serait ce que
pour ça parce que le combat restera une
histoire d'initiative et de
responsabilité et de récents et dire
j'avais dit qu'ils avaient tous deux
sujets merci de me le rappeler parce que
du sujet il est là de responsabilité des
tic au sens noble du terme effectivement
deux visions du monde
question internet que pense-t-il d'avoir
un seul porte-avions en france
indisponible cinq mois de tous les douze
mois + 10 18 mois tous les sept ans pour
changer les deux coeurs nucléaires j'en
profite pour imposer une la suite
combien de porte avions devrait voguer
sur les océans sous pavillon tricolore
pour que nous soyons crédibles et moi je
vais en rajouter non pour moi avoir un
porte avion quand il ya des missiles
hyper véloce qui peuvent se balader au
dessus de nos têtes est ce que ça vaut
encore l'intérêt autre que pour faire de
l'humanitaire
je vais d'abord répondre à la question
sur le nombre de porte avions il est
évident que n'en avoir qu'un ça n'est
pas une bonne solution c'est évident cc
même pas contestable donc vous ne me
ferez jamais dire que en avoir un et un
seul c'est une bonne chose non
ensuite il y à ce que l'on aimerait
avoir est ce que l'on peut avoir
est là encore dans un budget militaire
français en dessous de 2% du pib dans
les ressources actuellement allouées à
la marine française on ne peut pas avoir
de deuxième porte avions est ce que
c'est une bonne chose bien sûr non ils
sont que c'est pas possible et si
aujourd'hui vous disiez à la marine on
vous donne un autre porte avions mais
vous restez dans votre même périmètre
budgétaire vous tuez le reste de la
marine et vous ne permettez pas la
marine de bâtir l'équipage les deux
équipages dont elle aurait besoin pour
ses deux porte avions donc la réponse
est clairement en avoir qu'un ça n'est
pas une bonne chose mais les clairement
aussi également en même temps que
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas en avoir deux
combien faudrait-il en avoir
dans une
europe qui au delà du monde qui se
réarmer dans une europe qui se réarment
aussi si on se retrouve dans 10 ans ou
15 ans avec des anglais qui ont deux ou
trois porte-avions des espagnols et des
italiens quand des porte-avions et la
france qu'on a que 1 vieillit
vieillissant quel sera le rôle de la
marine français si à ce moment là le
rôle de la jeune française simplement de
pouvoir escorter de temps en temps quand
ils nous le demandent les porte-avions
britanniques italiens ou espagnols
est-ce que c'est ma vision et mon désir
pour notre pays la réponse est non
si on ne réagit pas
si les évolutions budgétaires qui ont
été promis par le président la
république mais pour le quinquennat
suivants ne sont pas confirmés si le
pays n'a pas cette conscience que le
monde comme on l'a déjà dit x fois
depuis que nous échangeons tous les deux
que le monde est plus dangereux que
jamais plus complexe que jamais eh bien
nous n'aurons que nos beaux yeux pour
pleurer lorsque tel le petit pays sous
développés que nous serons devenus de
temps en temps on sera content de japper
tel un petit chien autour des
porte-avions des autres pays européens
ici le ils peuvent alors les missiles
hyper véloce c'est l'éternelle question
de la cuirasse et
oui ça change la donne
bien sûr
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut être
tétanisé ne plus rien faire
et
amis si l'hyper véloce donné il faut
développer des contre mesures données
c'est-à-dire d'autres missiles
antimissiles et d'autres systèmes
d'armement et donc oui c'est miss et
libéraux lost arrive mais ça veut dire
une chose aussi c'est que nos missiles
anti défense ils vont profiter de cette
technologie et ils vont savoir pour
pouvoir y répondre
si on s'en occupe si on y met la
ressource budgétaire nécessaire bien
évidemment présenté quant aux élections
présidentielles à jamais et moi vous
pouvez me croire
question internet changement car on
essaie de leur formule 1 plus grand ça
d'ici changements climatiques futures
migration massive pénurie diverses il
faudra de la biodiversité tout ceci a
des effets systémiques engendrera
inévitablement des guerres est-ce que
l'armée et la marine ont pris en compte
tous ces facteurs et en sons et en
sont-ils conformer de manière réaliste
alors ce que cet internaute décrit est
parfaitement décrit pertinent et
intelligemment c'était vraiment une
bonne question la réponse est oui bien
sûr je vous en ai un seul exemple je
prends dans un autre c'est qu' il existe
à l'école de guerre ce qu'on appelle des
comités des comités c'est au coeur de
l'enseignement l'écolière mes cd s'est
intentionnellement dont j'avais confié
dans la grande réforme que je vais mener
à l'école de guerre dont j'avais confié
la direction aux officiers de la
promotion eux mêmes parce que ça
paraissait tout à fait important et donc
c'était à mes yeux ce qu'ils avaient
plus d'un de plus intéressant est de
plus important est que les gars étaient
ces comités et il y avait à peu près une
vingtaine de comités et l'un de ses
comités justement et j'espère qu'il
existe toujours c'était étudier les
conséquences géopolitiques des
évolutions environnementales et je peux
même vous dire que ce comité s'était
déjà fait en 2009 il y avait un colloque
est organisé sur alors il peut y avoir
des cas là c'est vraiment un comité
d'officiers qui travaillait toute
l'année sur le sujet et je peux même
vous dire que ce comité nous l'avions
lancé je l'avais lancé en partenariat
avec le wwf france
et donc c'était sous la houlette de
pascal canfin kanaté le directeur
général à l'époque et moi même ça ça a
étonné beaucoup de monde je suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs que le wwf se soit remis de
cette histoire parce que pascal canfin
qui était le directeur général de
l'époque isabelle autissier qui était la
présidente du bleuet sous le double
effet à l'époque et que tu te fais rami
avait parfaitement compris les enjeux
d'ailleurs nous avons été pascal canfin
et moi même auditionné à l'assemblée
nationale par la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée nationale et
marielle de sarnez qui qui qui vivait
encore à l'époque était de la président
de cette commission matile été sidéré
elle n'avait jamais vu la commission
aussi complète comme pour cette audition
donc c'est bien la preuve que ils
étaient tous le pen et mélenchon que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure il y était
donc c'est bien un sujet qui est compris
au moins par cette intention est en tout
cas dans les armées on y réfléchit
fortement est ce qu'on y apporte les
bonnes réponses ça c'est une autre
question c'est compliqué mais en tout
cas on en a une claire conscience
absolument mais c'est une vraie question
importante oui il y avait un truc qui a
été organisée aussi l'idée c'était les
red hot être les répercussions du
réchauffement climatique sur le livre
blanc de la défense française très
intéressant surtout sur les accords
méditerranéen
question d'internet je la retrouve
bonsoir mon amiral que pensez-vous de la
disparition de la sphère du sous marin
russe le koursk
gens pensent aux quêtes aujourd'hui est
connu par tous alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu là aussi c'est comme le bugale breizh
j'ai vu des tapes fantasme longtemps à
une époque aujourd'hui et souhaits
d'ailleurs les marines occidentales
savait depuis le début le court ce qui a
ni complot ni rien 1 il ya un explosion
à l'intérieur du bateau problème
l'une c'est torpille qui fait couler le
bateau c'est un accident interne ça
c'est le premier commentaire qu'on peut
le faire c'est factuel 2 ya
effectivement un pouvoir politique russe
poutine qui à l'époque tarder à réagir à
cette info
leur poule de diamants qui vient de
sortir et c'est exactement pour cela
c'est exactement cela mais pour cela le
pouvoir politique tarde à réagir lorsque
poutine se rend compte que ça une vraie
conséquence en interne sur l'opinion
publique russe il dit ok on peut agir à
ce moment là c'est trop tard et les
moyens d'intervention parce que parce
que pour agir il faut faire venir les
moyens d'intervention américain donc
c'est vrai qu'en plus qu'en français
non on ne savait pas nous-mêmes aller
les chercher on n'avait pas cette
capacité cette espèce de mini sous-marin
qui va ce clan paix sur l'autre sous
marins pour ensuite extraire l'équipage
sa non non non non c'est parce qu'elle
est vraiment passés par les américains
parce qu'à l'époque on se rend savait
pas faire et donc
réaction tardive du pouvoir russe qui
fait que effectivement alors qu'on sait
qui est du cir vivant pendant un certain
temps et qu on aurait probablement pu
alors pas tous des sceaux et parce
qu'une certain nombre une partie de
l'équipage a été tué lors de l'explosion
mais il ya effectivement alors est ce
que ces 10 15 20 ou 30 ans je ne sais
pas mais il ya quelques marins russes
qui si on avait réagi tout de suite
aurait pu être sauvée absolument est-ce
que l'histoire que c'est un sous-marin
américain qu'il a coulé tout ça c'est
n'importe quoi on arrive vers la fin
notre interview on va passer à des
questions plus détendu est-ce que vous
avez vu les archives de la navy
déclassifie où il ya des petites choses
qui se baladent dans les caméras les
ovnis qui se balade vous savez pas ce
que c'était est-ce que vous avez vu ça
non non ce n est là
la marine américaine a publié j'ai vu
détruits dans la presse oui pour
l'instant mais là encore je connais rien
est-ce que vous quand vous étiez sur
votre bateau où j'ai vu des trucs
bizarres j'ai vu plein de trucs bizarres
mais parfaitement identifiés est ce que
j'ai vu ce que j'ai vu alors si la
question est est ce que j'ai vu les
martiens d extrader rennes lille du
bonheur avec des boules vertes sur les
hommages et également technologie est ce
que vous avez vu des technologies qui
était tellement en avance que c'était
compliqué
non très honnêtement non très
honnêtement non vous avez vu ces images
je me souviens d'avoir vu un article
dans la presse lui m'a pas troublé pour
compass troublé parce que pour l'instant
je n'y crois pas cette histoire il prend
non sincèrement je ne sais pas ce que
c'est je sais pas répondre d'accord je
veux vraiment je vous raconterai des
consignes sur un terrain vantait de
question qu'un est faut-il sortir de
l'auto
c'est l'éternelle question c'est
l'éternelle question non résolue du est
ce que on fera plus facilement évoluer
un système en étant à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur
si vous me demandez est-ce que je suis
un grand fan de l'otan ma réponse et
vous l'avez déjà parlant compris et
n'ont
ensuite à part du moment où on en est
pas complètement satisfait
et rappelez vous tout ce qu'on sait
raconter tous les deux tout à l'heure
sur le parallèle facile entre la ligue
de délos et entre l'otan à partir du
moment où on en est pas satisfait sq
plutôt ma posture est-ce que c'est au
sein de l'otan qu'on pourra le mieux
agir ou à l'extérieur j'ai tendance à
penser en règle générale ou pour
répondre de manière théorique à cette
question théorique on change plus un
système quand on est dans son sac autant
de cantons mais à l'extérieur
qui tous
comment un amiral il se prépare à mourir
alors
c'est pas la première question qu'il
faut se poser prenez-en très simple je
n'ai que c'est pas la première vous
faites pas le coup c'est qu'est ce que
je dois faire pour rester pur ou
survivre maintenant non c'est pas la
première
la spécificité d'un militaire
contrairement à ce que la plupart des
gens croient ça n'est pas de donner sa
vie c'est pas vrai
sa spécificité c'est de porter la mort
au nom de la nation qui est la sienne et
qui le lui demande lorsque la nation
estime que c'est nécessaire c'est à dire
fascinant de voir comment vous retrouvez
là est la grande sagesse d'une époque
dont trop souvent on a raconté qu'elle
était obscur mais qu'on a appelé le
moyen âge où vous retrouvez les trois
grands hors de la société
les zorra torres ceux qui prient
les laboratoires s ceux qui travaillent
et les baies à torres ceux qui se
battent pour que ceux qui prient et
travaillent puissent prier travail et
c'est ceux qui prient qu'ils ont
dans une société démocratique pour
revenir à notre période vous avez une
catégorie de citoyens très particulière
et une seule ce sont les militaires
dont la spécificité est de porter la
violence au nom de la nation lorsque la
nation estime que c'est nécessaire moi
je suis plutôt heureux d'avoir fait ça
dans une nation démocratique
que dans une nation qui ne l'auraient
pas été mais en tout cas c'est ça leur
désert donc notre rôle à nous il est de
porter la mort il se trouve donc je
viens bien répondre à votre question et
se trouve que
emportant la mort nous acceptons de
donner notre vie et c'est cela qui
sauvera notre humanité
et donc un militaire qui n'accepteraient
pas
de mourir ou de pouvoir mourir serait
mais totalement dans l'incohérence
complète je vais même vous faire cette
confidence que
c'est pas très courageux peut-être mais
je suis assez heureux de terminer ma
carrière
avant que de plus en plus on porte la
mort sans prendre aucun risque
je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas le faire je
vous fais juste une confidence personnel
que toute ma vie j'ai été dans une
époque où les militaires dont je faisais
partie en portant la mort
pouvait
être obligé de donner leur vie et
c'était ça qui sauvé notre humanité
c'est ça qui sauvé mon humanité et j'en
étais heureux
dans un monde où passera la mort sans
prendre de risques
je suis assez heureux de ne pas
connaître cette période donc pour
répondre à cette question
est ce que le jour j j'aurais pas eu
peur ce que j'aurais pas eu la turista
j'en sais rien mais la question n'est
pas là mais en tout cas il me paraissait
totalement naturel que la contrepartie
de ma spécificité qui était porté la
mort était de pouvoir donner ma vie et
donc j'étais prêt est ontologiquement
j'étais prêt à perdre la vie et si je
n'avais pas été ç'aurait été totalement
incohérent
il y en a maintenant c'est bien est-ce
que vous avez trois livres a conseillé à
notre communauté ah oui absolument et ça
va pas être original pour ceux qui me
connaissent parce que mais je ne veux
qu'ils livrent déjà alors si vous voulez
parler de milliards si d'abord moi je
conseille étonnant de lire les livres de
loïc finaz ce bien évidemment mais c'est
pas ça ma réponse est passé à mes
attentes je vous faire larguer pas mal
et je vais vous faire je vous en
remercie ses clients d'ailleurs parlant
que vous le connaissez loïc finesse on
n'est pas compris mais blague si si si
mais je souhaite ne pas trop parler de
lui déjà déjà d'ailleurs il a été très
bavard ce soit il faut qu'il arrête non
j'ai offert la réponse que qui
correspond ou au conseil alors ils
rigolaient souvent ça les faisait rire
les officiers l'école de guerre pendant
les cinq années où j'étais dans cette
école parce que je leur conseillais très
souvent la lecture mais vous avez
supprimé la fiche du louis exactement
bref et aiguisé de manger plus fait
échouer ça débile imposé aux bascules un
an mais entre nous vous aviez supprimer
la liste de lecture oui je trouve ça
débile vous vous demandez pas des adn et
des hommes et les femmes de 38 ans
sur sélectionner un cd 20% meilleur
d'une population qui a déjà été
extrêmement sélectionné bond en avant
qui sort de 15 ou 20 ans de vie
opérationnelle et cette génération est
une génération qui a connu naguère qui
fait la guerre ils sont remarquables
vous leur faites pas une liste de
lecture comme des petits écoliers c'est
n'importe quoi donc moi ça m'énerve mais
revanche jeu dans nos échanges parce que
j'avais beaucoup d'échangés avec eux et
d'ailleurs c'était de loin ce que j'ai
préféré l'école guerre ces échanges que
j'ai eus pendant cinq ans avec ses
officiers passionnant est remarquable je
leur faisais souvent pas de mes propres
lectures et je leur donnais des conseils
de youtube mais très officiellement et
d'ailleurs ça se retrouve dans mes
disques le discours inaugural que j'ai
cette année je conseillais 3 libre donc
ce sont ceux-là plus encore que tous les
autres que je vais conseiller je
conseille d'abord de l'irl usage de
monde de nicolas bouvier
der et paix de tolstoï et les enfants
français alors si vous pouvez lire en
russe allez-y en russe mais la
traduction française est très bonne et
très honnêtement moi je les les lure
l'élu en français et
les enfants jéromine de r n'b shirt
lisez-le usage du monde si vous voulez
effectivement comprendre le monde et
nicolas bouvier pour cela est tout à
fait passionnant atteint sans lire si
vous voulez comprendre la guerre lisez
tolstoï je peux même vous dire que j'ai
relu parce que je l'avais lu qu'il y
avait 20 ans mais j'ai relu quand
j'étais à l'école de guerre tolstoï
pendant le mois 11 et faire de la
planification militaire aux officiers de
l'école est vraiment d'ailleurs je leur
ai dit je ne suis pas frisé je dois dire
mais vraiment je me disais qu'on
pourrait supprimer ce mois de
planification c'est pas toujours très
drôle c'est même franchement pas drôle
militaire et je vous dirai je vous donne
une semaine pour lire guerre et paix en
fait ça serait beaucoup plus utile et
lisez les enfants jérôme inc est le plus
beau roman que j'ai jamais lu parce que
ça vous fera comprendre l'humanité donc
bouvier pour la compréhension du monde
tolstoï pour la compression de la guerre
et les shirt pour la compréhension de
l'humanité ce que vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissables
soyez vous-même
et n'ayez pas peur
mon amiral merci c'est moi remercier de
leur accueil
[Musique]
non